april 29th 1pm it's friday baby
[Applause]
it's
friday you're here you rolled up you're
flexing on us
show up that unreleased
teddy fresh which is
coming out soon that looks so fire
hold on okay
you want to put your feet up so we can
get a full fit check
i mean
sure it's all happening
you know little grandpa look smelly feet
yeah no it's all happening it's all here
graham for a question i've heard that
women do this uh-oh
do you ever just shave your ankles
um
if
if i need to yes interesting there you
have it did you guys know that
i know someone that does that
oh really
you does it happen to be your wife
it's me
you do that you shave your
ankles wait what why do you shave your
ankles
it's lena i didn't want to expose her
well
it's fine i mean it's a thing that that
women do and god bless them for that
yeah
yeah sometimes you got to do what you
got to do exactly to be presentable to
the world no i get it i feel like if i
if that was something that i did i would
do that every day because we all got to
pretend that we don't have hair on our
body yeah i'm not doing i'm not doing
all that i'm just shaving the ankles
you know
i can't even
i can't even be uh bothered to shave my
face and here i am i'm like an
entertainer i'm in front of the camera
uh lena you just got exposed by a bee
shaving your ankles
she just stepped in she was she was afk
hold on
for shaving your ankles sometimes you
know if you're like you know you're
working hard and you need to go
somewhere and you may show your ankles
and you didn't have a chance to shave
we were just saying how it's common
amongst women i said i know a girl that
does that ethan presley no no you said
no you said i know a person no person
does that oh it's well it's not really
exposing i mean it's the same as shaving
your legs thank you
that's exactly what i was saying very
cool
[Applause]
unashamed
proud queen
i'm just kidding guys
they're saying nice fit lina nice fit
lina nice bit lino
i just thought it was interesting you
know you get insights into the uh
whatever you guys find interesting yeah
what is the guy i wonder what's
something that guys do
that women would find surprising
you know what i mean
as far as like grooming habits yeah just
in general
um
i gave their armpits i got one do you
use a washcloth in the shower to clean
your ass
i've heard you're supposed to do that
right that's like a thing yeah wait you
use it well i know people use washcloths
so if i'm using a washcloth
or a uh what do you call those sponges
i'll use it to wash my ass but like not
inside my ass is that what you mean i
heard you're supposed to use a washcloth
no no no
he that's not what he means inside your
ass no like you could like wipe your
butthole
when you're taking when you're taking a
shower when you're taking a shower
i heard you're supposed to thoroughly
clean your ass by putting some soap or
whatever lather it up on the towel and
really get
in that corner maybe if you're
absolutely about to get eaten but who
takes care of the dirty washcloth
well you you do a pre-soak before before
you do that so you keep it in the shower
more concerned with after
there might be a little brown town on
there but yeah
i'm not saying i do it
i'm a hand guy you know what have you
ever done you shove your hand up there
credit card style with some soap yeah
i'm never shaking your hand again that's
disgusting i mean i know because i
washed in the shower
that's true stick your hand up your
[ __ ] ass when i shower you don't wash
your ass don't scour and swipe my own
ass he's got a i mean zack is he's
practicing cleanliness you don't you
don't put soap in your ass in the shower
amy
well do you wash your ass whole because
i'm not sure that that's like sometimes
if it's like real messy down there i've
been having like a week of diarrhea what
do you guys mean like well you can walk
you wipe your butt you can wash your
butt okay but then there's the hole oh
like going in do you wipe don't you
actually get to the hole and soap it up
you know
so i think that i think the credit card
analogy is perfect yeah yeah it's
expensive
no
yeah but there's but you know what i'm
saying like you can clean the hole
itself or you could just swipe it
sure correct but you need to but you're
yeah okay you need a more thorough swipe
to really get a you know this is this is
american express you know so where did
you hear that
what the credit card analysis no about
that you need to use a washcloth to
clean the ass i think i saw something on
twitter or something like that where
it's like you need to thoroughly can we
fact check that because i'm pretty sure
there's no chance that that's true
i mean humans been existing for a long
time without wipe without uh
washclothing our [ __ ]
i'm not talking necessarily like put it
up your [ __ ] i'm just using it well i
think i misunderstood zach i think he's
talking about bare hand no in the shower
yeah bare hand in the shower you're bare
handing swiping your ass well what are
you doing
i use a loofah
oh you do so you luffy your [ __ ] so
you're no better than that yeah i'm not
wait wait wait okay okay hold on
hold on
when you when you take a shower
yeah you get in the shower you know you
hit the water first and you soap up
under your arms and on your chest and
stuff like that what do you do to clean
your butt
i use a loofah every time to wash your
ass i never put my bare hand in my
[ __ ] no why not
i mean you're in the shower yeah with
soap i do i bare hand my ass interesting
in the shower with soap of course yes
right you know
interesting
because the loofah goes on the rest of
your body right yeah in no particular
order but it's not like i'm getting like
up in the the hole it's just like the
cheeks can i ask you a question yeah and
you hit on something really good ela
when you when you guys wash your body do
you hit the ass area last
because you don't want like you said to
spread the ass
around the rest of the body yeah i do
that area left you do i i go i do i like
i work down like washing a car you know
so you do you know chest area belly
button i always get the belly button and
then i do the balls the gooch in the ass
that's that's good yeah do you wash your
feet or you just let the soap run over
it just let the soap run over so you
don't wash your feet i feel like that'd
be like
i actually started washing my legs and
specifically my toes because i noticed
that when i clip my nails now i don't
have fungus and my toes are looked nice
regular i mean they're they're you're
number one on wiki feet
exactly
you guys have seen my feet you know what
they look like
but i noticed when i was clipping my
toenails it stunk really bad
like just a really like if you smell the
nail yeah or even just smell your
fingers afterwards it's like a really
pungent smell it's gross but what i
noticed is when i started actually
getting down there and washing my legs
because i was like you you let the water
run and you think that's enough it's not
enough you wash your legs and then your
feet and your you get in the toes
the smell is gone so do you bend over
and do it in the shower or do you like
you know i me i meet in the middle
or i'll put my foot up you know i put my
foot up there's usually like a little
stand there in the shower right yeah
yeah so i recommend definitely washing
the feet and toes okay i'll get on with
i'll get another
what's what's in another opinion i want
to smell feet oh you want oh okay oh
okay okay first of all
white claw gabe in the building it is
friday
oh
where are we today
tgif tgif baby
hey god it's friday where are you
that's where he i think he's there right
oh you're literally at tgif
oh
what'd you
get
i got wings
fries oh my god diet coke and then maybe
some sunday later
tg i have baby [ __ ] yeah baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] baby
what's your plans for saturday sunday
and monday
um so we're gonna do something fun with
the family tomorrow i wanted to ask you
about coachella how was it i mean
everyone was admiring your fit by the
way your fit was went hard great man
it's great
i enjoyed it a lot it's kind of dusty
they don't have unpleasant bathroom it's
mostly porta potties
it's a great experience so you tell me
all the beautiful girls with all their
beautiful outfits go potty in a porta
potty hell no they have vips
okay
yeah i got vip but all the all the stuff
that's all porta-potty that cat
wow did you have to take a dump in a
porter potty
i did once oh it's disgusting oh my god
did you oh we got your fit up on the
screen i gotta ask did you put your
outfit together or do you have a stylist
um well i kind of have someone else help
me with my
choosing the outfit oh you do
okay yeah all right
was it your um what your what's your
relation with the guy who usually you're
with that's your cousin or your nickname
it's kind of like my nephew kind of like
oh your nephew right right
was it was it nick that helped you with
the fit
yeah yeah
that's all he knows what's best what's
for coachella either coachella
so tell me about when you took the dump
in the porta potty was it like uh
did you have to squat did you sit on the
seat or did you have to squat oh no
it wasn't that controlled but it has to
be in a football game where i was like
urgent so i kind of like i just kind of
like i don't want to touch it but i just
like kind of like aim it towards the
thing oh [ __ ]
and what did it like squirt or you plop
it in there
it kind of squirt
oh yeah baby
yeah so you were having a little
diarrhea
that wasn't that good but i wasn't
another
all right well you've got to do what you
got to do we all know that
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby
that's great experience you know i'm
glad you had fun
i'm thinking about going to tgif today
it's friday after all it is friday yeah
it did is it good do you recommend it
it's it's good you know there's a lot of
stuff that i tried to i tried the um
ribs it's pretty good and some fries
all right and that's a good sundae hell
yeah and fish and chips oh we feel like
fish
okay
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby [ __ ] [ __ ]
suck
[Laughter]
yeah he's working he's got a he's got a
few new uh tools in the
eli it's been a while do you have any
stuff you want a workshop on ila
um i know of course cop energy
yeah i love that one yeah
i know pissing my ass [ __ ] pissing my
ass baby [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how about [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah that's a classic classic
i'm a [ __ ]
all right buddy well
i don't want to i don't want to
interrupt your meal there yeah your food
is getting cold it's a beautiful friday
for a beautiful meal at tgif
gif thank god it's right thank god
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
friday baby friday baby oh
friday [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby
[ __ ] baby
baby [ __ ] yeah
my dick shut my body
yeah
baby it's friday
[Applause]
everybody's in the good mood it's friday
oh yeah
all right you take care okay have a good
weekend take care bye bye
bye
bye bye
ciao
that was a good one oh he actually hung
up
[Applause]
i was just gonna let it hang
indefinitely that time yeah no i yeah
that's good
how about tgif for dinner
i never have you been there you know
what i like that they do there
they have these a nacho platter but it's
only like eight chips and each one is
like perfect oh i think you told me
about that bro i live for that
great jello shots dude
yellow shirts yellow shine what the hell
is i'm not ordering that at a restaurant
it seems kind of crazy
it's like they mix
alcohol and jello
no way and then you put jello in a shot
glass and then you just eat the jello
right yeah exactly you've never
experienced that before no no i guess
it's yeah it's probably just an american
like college staple
oh no it's are you real yeah we're being
serious totally serious
yeah it's so crazy that you think we're
lying to you huh
yeah no i mean this is it's a jello shot
you just put the jello and it's got like
vodka in it
does it taste
it tastes like ass yeah it tastes like
alcohol
but i guess it's supposed to melt but it
has like gooey texture like jello yeah
it's jello you slurp and it goes down
like a shot yeah
some people think it's easier it's not
that bad yeah i'm what you doing this
weekend i'll show you okay you want to
do jello shots this weekend we can make
a whole thing about it yeah let's do it
yo we're about to turn the [ __ ] off this
weekend though
i've never seen this
i think you might enjoy them either
they're from i mean i like the colors
already yeah it's fun it's just a fun
stupid thing
mine won't look this nice though it'll
just be like red
so we have no sponsors today so
if you want to support the show if you
want to support us
or if you want some cool clothing head
on over to teddyfish.com
showcasing today
the floral jacquard terry camp shirt
which a b is
modeling for us today
go ahead damn son
okay
i love the tag how does it feel oh the
tag show let me see
red classic teddy fresh how does it feel
baby it feels great i love it reminds me
that shirt you guys released last summer
the terry one yeah sure yeah i love this
material thanks bro and like never
wrinkles
yeah that's true right it does not
yeah it's a really fun shirt it's
awesome so
there you go that's that's just you know
give you an idea but get over the
website see if there's something you
like there's all kinds of stuff there
thank you abe
thank you
um oh there's a new bts for members so
shout out to and thank you to all of our
members oh it'll be up after the show
after the show post it right after we go
off live by the way i had uh polled the
audience with the uh the how do you
watch your ass debate and uh oh i didn't
realize that was happening yeah
diversity of uh answers here um but
just doing it with your hand is the
clear winner with 62 percent of the vote
uh luffa 23 and sorry zach but the
washcloth is down in third place at 15
percent so i'm not saying i do that no i
know you aren't but you you had said
that you heard you're supposed to do
that but i heard you're supposed to do
yeah i mean i use my hand and i think
the washcloth just on face value no
hates act seems to be the most
disgusting because it's just going to
pick up any [ __ ] particles well i think
the loth class
wash cloth in general is kind of a
disgusting concept to begin with
well it's like an old-school loofah
that's my problem like it's like what do
you do with it when it's dirty right
it's a one-time use otherwise it gets
like disgusting do you throw it in the
trash
you gotta wash it you just wash it yeah
but then you've got this damp disgusting
towel it's tough yeah the loofah is
clearly the innovation past
i used to use luffa but i think i got
over it because um
you kind of
made me feel disgusted from by the
loofah why because because it was
touching my body no no because like you
made me aware with you and now it's
[ __ ] not because of that like i think
you were like
it gets gross and then i was like oh my
god it's gross you know what we started
to notice when we used the loofah
is that they're starting to get lit i
think what it was was just a lint and
stuff because there's a lint all over
your body
but there's just little specks of [ __ ]
that gets stuck inside the maze of the
loofah yeah it's skin the whole point of
the loop is whatever yeah whatever it is
in there humans bad vibes once you
pointed it out i was like i'm out
so do you wash the loofah or do you like
just use it a few times and then get a
new one
personally
throw it out throw it out you don't wash
the loofah you get but you use it for a
long time right like
yeah uh i don't know i'd say yeah
so i i like the i'm back on the bar soap
i like the bar so yeah you know
what's one thing that us guys do that
women don't know i feel like that's oh
here's one tuck the dick under the belt
i may have told you about that but did
you know yeah i didn't know about it
before like sam do you know that guys
tucked their dick under the belt
i i did know that life hack oh so
everyone knows that lina did you know
about that i
i don't really know what you're talking
about what i've never talked to my dick
in my belly
if you're in a public setting and you
get an erection that's like um you can't
control it like i just back in like
middle school yeah
okay i didn't realize i used to get on
the bus every day yeah yes that move
yeah of course you put it under your
waistline yes okay i understand now to
hide it no that's essential that's
essential
i was like the fact i already know it
because i think you told the story but
wait so sam knew that lena did you know
about that no i've never heard of that
so there you go i think most women don't
know about that
so what it is is you when you get
uncontrollable erections
usually as a teenager when you can't you
have just no control of your body you
learned that in middle school for sure
yeah like i would get them on the bus
from the subtle gyre like just the
subtlest motion yeah i'm fully torqued
and then the bus arrives and like you're
pulling into school you're and you're
like please god
please god you're just meditating you're
like please god
just
make my boner go away
it's still fully torqued by the time you
pull in so you got to be slick and tuck
it under your belt real fast so you can
walk for crazy
that gets my dick hard yeah i missed the
component of this of this being masking
the boner because i i just thought that
was just something you're just casually
doing on a regular basis that was
to midnight so wait love you never done
that
um i don't know no i've never talked to
the upwards no what do you do
well i i think it would be more more of
a side thing not straight up seems kind
of risky
i don't know the height thing
yeah well i mean the angle can not the
angle can it can vary depending on but
the side thing you see it it's like all
out there right well the whole point is
you don't want to question it in the
chat does that hurt
no it doesn't hurt at all it's just it's
just up against the body it's like the
natural yeah another person is saying it
sounds so stressful it is that's what
i'm saying you guys it's not that you
guys you want to talk about the
patriarchy well talk well you've never
tucked your dick in your belt and had
existential dread when pulling into
school that's true thank you
fresh and fit i love from science
totally on board with this this is the
episode about how it shrinks in the
cold then you have shrinkage
elaine comes to the
scene and i don't know what they tell
her and she's like i don't know how you
guys walk around with those they go
elaine you don't know about shrinkage
yeah
when you're in this she's like laundry
yeah
hi i'm dick tip so so that's a good one
let's do a poll how many women only vote
for this did you know about the dick
under the waistline yes or no
if you will show results
so
dudes don't vote and then do the third
one that says i'm a dude
okay so if you really want to vote you
know you can say i'm a dude
i'd like to give an update if you guys
remember when ethan cut my hairs
on the show
a new trim this that you see right here
and now they're just stuck like that let
me cut it again throw them no
give me someone get me a raise they
can't worse so now i have to wait to see
what happens are we with harry's or what
which one are we on i'll give you a sh
go give you a goodie because last time
you were supposed to cut like a single
hair well
i thought it was a whole bunch let me
see it's a gang
it grew fast though it did go fast
but it's like stuck now
yeah so every time you see that you know
okay so 51
said yes
20
26 percent said no lena didn't know
about it so i mean that's that's a
substantial amount for something that i
feel like we're all
yeah that's forced to reckon with a good
amount of lives changed today
[Laughter]
i mean
it is interesting though that the yeses
uh are far higher than the nose because
i mean isn't the whole point of that
move so that people don't know if that
many people know
i don't know how effective it really is
well they only find out about it later
in life
i don't think they know that you're
walking at the time
interesting i'm kind of curious about
how many dudes do it because i don't
know i i i i can am i tell you
here love
maybe you use this move instead because
this this was an alternate approach is
when you're in school you have your
backpack
and you you suddenly need to find
something in your backpack and you're
digging through it and you put it in
front of you to kind of mask the whole
region right right you know you're just
kind of pretending to dig through as a
way of that's that's another way that
that situation could be handled so
i just don't see how straight up would
be comfortable you know
i mean i don't see any other way to
solve that issue frankly
you know all right
i think but but like if you obviously
you figured out something you got
through middle school so
god bless you know
i see some people saying that they're
they're leg tuckers they tuck it down
instead into the pants
if you're torn how does it stay down uh
i guess just from the pressure of the
pants i mean
people are kind of painful but they
built a little differently too first of
all you see it right i mean the thing
about the belt tuck is that you cover it
with your shirt right it's concealed
the the boner naturally goes up
at least mine does i don't know maybe
something goes to the ground people's
bodies are different you know yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah there you go
no direction shaming no direction
your dick goes down god bless you
some people lots of people saying they
tuck sideways love so you're not alone i
don't know how that technically works
though
i guess it's just
side words a little bit upwards if i
don't i feel like we're getting way too
detailed here um
you don't have maybe yeah yeah yeah
you don't have to uh i'm tapping out get
into it
rascal
[Laughter]
i'm trying to think if there's anything
else the boner thing's pretty good
but
um
as far as oh here's
one what you got
that sometimes
i guess this is pretty common
where dudes will jerk off before
a date or before having sex i feel like
i've heard about i try to last longer
movies maybe or something but i i don't
think i've ever done that maybe i have
but apparently that's a common thing
did you ladies know about that
maybe that's been in popular media too
much did not know about that one okay
there you go lina
okay so so wow i'm so there we're
breaking ground are you spilling the
beans here i'm so savvy giving away the
secret giving away
i found a good one so the theory is if
you bust one out then you can
you can last longer that's the theory
right yeah yeah and not just nervous and
mess up then date is it about calming
your nerve is it about yeah being less
like horny or is it about lasting longer
no it's about both clearing the mind
clear the mind it's about drive it's
about power yeah
again
seinfeld they did it all but it's like
when uh
george
he's like smarter when right right when
he doesn't when he's not foreign
or something like that yeah he stopped
having sex for a month or something or
what was it actually it's no
masturbation and no sex no nothing and
then he gets smarter because his
girlfriend like had some type of there
was a reason they couldn't have sex and
like he becomes a genius and gets every
jeopardy question right people are
saying calming the nerves so actually
i'm curious now because two of the
ladies here didn't know that
let's go to the poll same thing dan
i want to find the most obscure man fact
did you ever open my room about
yeah you don't go out with a loaded gun
that's what they said pre-juice right
pre-juice come no come
yeah calm down man
so you have the emptying the chamber
and then you know about emptying the
trainer yes no
i have a penis so i am sitting this one
out
i always think of the scene and there's
something about mary
yeah yeah yeah yeah i actually that's
how i learned about the birds and bees
was from that scene oh my goodness the
birds on the beach my grandma explained
it to me
you watch this go watch this av
i watched it then ask questions yeah you
know the other one i can think about
okay so this one actually has
more people know about this than
than the dick tuck which is interesting
right or yeah
i feel like it's about even actually no
what about this one did you know that
like i can't speak for you guys but i
think all guys is are you know that
dudes are paranoid about their balls
getting twisted
no do you guys ever fear that right here
dude
like oh yeah not me no no twisted yeah
so my item maybe it's my mom's fault she
my mom is has been traumatizing my whole
life and she always does it she goes
i'm like 10 years old and my mom goes
yeah so anyway i uh uh she would always
be like clients of mine because my mom
was a hairdresser she would always come
home with these ridiculous stories about
my client told me this and that
she goes my client's son got his his
balls twisted he just woke up and his
balls were twisted and he had to go to
the hospital and get surgery and i was
like thanks mom i'm thinking about that
for the rest of my life even now oh my
god
so when i'm going to bed did that even
happen
they're free floating yeah they're just
kind of
and then around and i think wouldn't you
yeah they call it here they have a name
for their back
tourism yeah it's a real thing
testicular
torsion portion
so like my whole life i'm like oh my god
my balls are just floating there could
be a twist at any time
and it's just absolutely
so there you go
balls can get twisted
do we learn this in school and uh they
even said that
if you let it like leave it twisted for
too long they die
they literally said that well i think
they start swelling and it's extremely
painful so you'd be kind of insane to
not treat that but i guess
so like
i i can't underst i don't understand
what could happen that is a problem look
you got you your sack you got the sack
yes there's two balls okay with like
wires
tubes okay you got balls and tubes yeah
they get twisted you like
this inside the sack they get twisted
yeah that's pretty scary
oh here's a comment i knew a kid
that got testicular torsion in his sleep
and had to be rushed to the hospital for
surgery too permanent fear for those of
my life yeah
you know
i'm not sure that i would go home and
tell our our sons about that
like hey sons gather around i want to
traumatize you for life
i mean they it might be good information
to know so you know like if it happens
you know
what's going on and if you're an
excruciating pain yeah i guess you'll
you'll know yeah you're right but i kind
of feel like it's a lot of kids would
probably not say it because it's kind of
awkward so you can embarrass your
parents that you your nuts are hurting
maybe it is good to just i think it's
going to lay it all out there
holy [ __ ] i i would have preferred not
know about it
personally maybe the way to say it is
just
no
it's very rare but if your balls start
hurting tell me yeah it's like not that
prevalent you don't need to do a ball
stop with your kids so i kind of i have
a story about there was one time i hit
my brother in the ball so hard
and he he was younger he must have been
like five or six
and i i hit him so hard he was in such
pain but i was so fearful of telling my
parents that i just hit my brother and
he was walking around with horrible
[ __ ] pain crying and my mom's like
what's wrong and i kept telling him like
don't say anything don't say anything
and eventually he boss you know he he
gave up and he said zach hit me in the
ball super hard so we had to rush him to
the er and he had an ultrasound on his
[ __ ] balls thankfully he's okay
his balls were fine yeah so why'd you
hit why did you hit him in the balls as
i was being a you know dicky big brother
you punch him you kick him it was it was
a kick you kicked him in the balls yeah
holy [ __ ] dude yeah
you never fought with your brother
growing up ethan
i did but
my my big my brother was a good guy he
never he never [ __ ] with me in that
way never kicked me in the balls or
anything that's good
well anyway moving on
um let's talk about ian did you i don't
know if you saw but ian had this human
superhuman
oh yeah
of eating the strosin i did watch that
um
actually let's let's can you give me
that time stamp i want to relive it but
whatever that was very impressive i
don't know how he did i don't know how
he does that man clap those cheeks
there's some theories
about that what are you saying there's
been some accusations yes
yeah so someone has brought up an
interesting theory for it
that the covid has stunted his taste and
that's the reason why he's able to do it
do you have answers to that charge
verona i think it's absurd there's no
evidence here i've recovered my taste
well there is i mean you say there's no
evidence well let me ask you this let me
ask this
the first time you ate the fish was that
before or after you got covered it was
after oh okay well then then we have a
problem it was last fall there is a
pattern of behavior what are you afraid
of ian
here's here's the clip for those who
didn't see it
truly a remarkable feat i mean
i again i i've been saying and i truly
believe i don't think there's many
people in the world
that can do what ian did but don't
people eat this
not like this they don't eat it like how
do they eat it they cook it they put it
with food
i've i've been told i asked my mom
exactly how you eat it yeah apparently
you put it in thin bread with creme
fraiche onions and you cut tiny tiny
pieces apparently and you
wash it wash it before
yeah so right so
you don't need it
it's i'm just i tasted it i smelled it
i thought you were going to puke on the
table there i i puked
a bee
yeah ian how did you feel
that whole day afterwards fine not good
oh really i i actually did puke at home
oh oh and that's when it got me when you
start pulling the [ __ ] out of your mouth
yeah i i get so i'm like about to
yeah
i
oh what is this stan
uh oh this is you eating a raw onion and
saying
no problem doesn't taste like give it
some audio yeah
i literally had some scratch music right
as i got cold
this he had
i'm just saying there's no evidence of
this here's the other
just to give it a fair shake bro i don't
really taste anything that's it that
that wasn't correct
what's the date on this clip
it is december 6 2020 so yeah it was a
minute ago almost two years ago you're
about long covered right
right i guess but do people lose their
taste for for long cove is that a long
cove it's just symptom where you lose
your tastes permanently i don't think so
i don't think anybody knows anything yet
and i think ian needs to be studied
i do think ian used to be study but not
but not because of his i'm gonna knock
of taste i'm gonna defend ian here thank
you uh
putting the taste
you know aside the mere fact of the
cousin consistency
and just the mere fact of having that in
your body
no it's incredible nothing can take
we're having a little fun we're doing a
little trolling okay
but nothing can take away this this this
feat
and sam some would say that sam suffered
the most what was your yeah what was
your reaction to spending the day with
him
he stunk so bad
once again like every he was burping all
day and every burp was like opening a
fresh can
it was like over and over and over again
and the smell like lingered
that's like opening the can like it was
insane and then he threw up at home did
the puke stink in yes our hole oh my god
no way we had to open like every window
what was it like puking that out ian
well i i i forced myself to puke because
i kept
the burpees
i kept going like
and i was tasting i was reliving it
over and over and over and i'm like
i'm going to the bathroom i'm going to
try and make this stop and i was just i
made myself throw up and it was like i
did it all over again it was horrible
that is horrific yeah not to be too
nasty that is awful i'm i'm very
interested
uh somebody somebody donated ten dollars
maggie said i got covered in january
2020 and nothing tastes or smells right
still does dan always have to be like
this dan is the hater he is being yeah i
mean there is a reason we have a song
listen he does he does uh bring up an
interesting point why are you like this
dan my friend lost his taste for eight
months from coven but it's been two
years ian's
in january 2020 that's almost a year
before ian and they nothing tastes or
smells right still
but they say nothing smells right or
tastes right but they're still tasty
sam you know him better than anyone
what's your take on this contract right
no he can he can taste and smell pretty
normally again i think and do you think
you would
yeah
do you think you would have been able to
do this before covet
i mean i don't know as a kid like when i
i would watch fear factor a lot i always
was like i could do that yeah
i don't know
i think if he can do i i think ian is a
superhuman you got a talent yeah
and actually i want to explore that
talent more
i don't know about that
well here's the video of you guys
driving home
what i just burped i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i think she might actually be crying
my eyes were burning
[Music]
oh my god
[Laughter]
was the hundred dollars you got worth it
sam or no
honestly next time
next time i'm doing 250 at least
it wasn't enough
well talk to ian because first of all i
put up 500 for ian
then there was like three people that
donated 100 right
something like that
and then
um jablonski
friend of the show
he's a famous uh
music uh composer for movies
good guy great guy
he texted me
and he's like what i just witnessed was
a super human feat
and he's like what's what's uh ian's
venmo i want to match you yep
that's really cool so thanks to
jablonski and everyone who else who
added
ian cleaned up 1500 bucks yeah for
eating that fish oh my god thank you
thank you
thank you jablonski and whoever donated
that
fear factor i was not expecting that
that was so cool of everybody i
appreciate it
yeah jay balonsky always comes in with
the
legendary moves
he's he's the best it'll cover the
knight he's such a sweet guy him and his
family and his wife third he always just
you know we won't hear about it
yeah we want and then we'll get like a
card from them like
no i like that with them it's so nice no
i mean in a nice way like they they're
always on it with jesus this is
jablonski
but no we we we text back and forth a
bit here and there he's legend
uh jablonski imdb let's check his uh
let's check his stats
but anyway so
ian cleaned the f up eh
amazing
so
would anyone else do that for 1500 bucks
or was is that still
absolutely not no
you wouldn't do it for 1500 no
would you dan i mean i mean no because i
don't
i don't eat fish but
if i did i would fifteen hundred dollars
i don't know he did puke yeah it's a
good amount of money he did all the
music for uh the transformers and i
think he's getting bigger and bigger
he's just doing a lot of big projects
what was that with housewives
eight years
eight seasons but he's he's he's
starting to he's starting to move up too
i think starting to do big projects but
anyway shout out that's my housewives
was like
one of the biggest shows on tv one yeah
right it was always huge yeah it was a
huge thing what was that show about i
don't know i don't know that i ever
watched it but i know like always
hearing that name it was a uh like a
prime time drama that was on abc abc
back in the day it was huge
maybe even dramady i don't know
see much of it so shout out ian
thank you thank you thank you
that was amazing man
[Applause]
that was incredible what you did there
that day
um
also i don't know wearing that hat and
the long hair you kind of looked like a
survivalist
oh true
that's a very nice way to play you gotta
you gotta do what you got it's a good
way though
you gotta get those calories somehow
it was cool
yeah you know later that night i was
home and i just licked it and i mean i
was sitting right in front of the can i
was in close proximity but i was i was
just smelling it on my clothes and stuff
and i had to like just i had to throw i
just had to take everything off and
shower
they just kept getting whiffs of it and
i was just unbelievable
when we uh
went downstairs after we did that
segment there were teddy fresh people
leaving the building and i was like can
you smell from downstairs and they were
like we're going to have to air it out
holy crap
chantal wanted to like bug bomb the
place
down the stairs yeah it was very
prominent downstairs i walked off that's
one can you guys understand that's just
one can of fish boy
love says his room still smells
oh is that true love
yeah dude i [ __ ] regret it so much
everything is [ __ ]
what's funny though
all right what is this some johnny depp
memes let's see i'm johnny that's heard
he's wearing makeup in every one of
those video clips correct
all right
so
wait what the [ __ ]
so this is
like a pre-recorded deposition with uh
somebody
he was what the bodyguard security guard
at his penthouse
and he chose to do it from
his car while vaping and driving well
you'll see look he's a working-class man
he ain't got time no no it's hilarious i
love that he did this he's [ __ ]
2016.
you saw her the night of may 25th
correct
correct she said
amber heard hundreds of people
he's like lucky for you guys you can
take all this time off to go to court i
got [ __ ] pills to pay
all right this is my last question you
testified in response to mr presidio's
questions um that you
this is so distracting
he's not wearing his seatbelt too
truthfully to everything that you
testified
that's correct
i did
so that was john
johnny's bodyguard or doorman or
something don't you feel like they
should have said like would you mind
please parking while we talk to you
i was hoping he'd go through a
drive-through at some point yeah hold on
[Music]
all right it's a good time to break for
lunch uh we'll just break a little early
just don't talk to anybody don't do any
outside research and we'll see you at
two o'clock okay that was pretty much it
that's
gonna be me and ryan kavanagh if we got
a jury you gotta see what the judge said
yeah oh all right listen to what the
judge is okay
oh that was what i saw this reaction i
didn't know it was that
she's like what
[Laughter]
she's flabbergasted
this is weird
she keeps making faces i remember
that was the first i'm sorry
that is the most bizarre episode okay
all right
like i said
you deposed me on my time
just saying just saying
what is this
what happened oh super chat that says
andy dick talking mad smack about you on
his lives
i don't know oh join the club wait is
andy dick a right winger or something
no andy dick is an andy dick dude he's
yeah he's a woman what could andy dick
possibly have beef with me he's in a
league of his own dude andy if you're
watching do you remember when you came
to my house in like 2007 and
stayed up until four in the morning
doing coke and like harassing all my
friends because that's a thing like that
wait what we've told you
i feel like everyone here has a handy
dick story all right i have many too i'm
with dan we have so many andy dick
stories wait pull that clip yeah right
probably on his instagram because that's
where you i've been looking i'm checking
instagram what was he doing at your
house because of your parents good
question he just rolled up no he
came into the restaurant that i worked
at at the time and a good friend of mine
who was another waitress she
served him and he took a liking to her
and they kind of like started texting
and then it was like the next day or
something she texts me she's like i'm
coming over uh and i'm bringing somebody
wait i was like okay you guys were how
old i was like
20 21 and hey
oh he's probably in his 50s he's old
he's a weirdo i don't know if you guys
know he ended up getting arrested for uh
sexually assaulting somebody like a week
later oh he did yep oh man he is so he's
deranged he's like you can't like bring
him around he's acting like
it's sad because he really is funny and
talented and he's just
yeah well so is bill cosby just saying i
was going to know him
i was at a comedy show last night and um
andy dick being a creep a prolific creep
was a big part of the show actually oh
andy i almost verbatim what dan just
said that everyone has a
andy anybody who grew up in la there's
like a very good chance that andy dick
crashed a party well i love that for you
he's like always great
and he's joined the club
going in enjoying the party everybody
hating i was sitting in malibu one night
and he was i saw him he was drunk as a
skunk and he came up and this was pete
covid
and he came up and kissed me on the
forehead
how is he getting around this much that
he's at he's interacting with two people
on the crew
in an inappropriate way appropriately
yeah he um he
he essayed uh one of my friends that
night actually
yeah
he grabbed grabbed his dick
straight up just like unprompted just
went for it
so what did you say about me andy
because apparently you shouldn't be
saying [ __ ] about anybody
you shouldn't you should just sew your
mouth shut and move to antarctica or
something because
i'm not finding this anywhere i mean his
instagram story shows him partying with
like a bunch of 20 year olds last night
does it just happen maybe you can
contact the person who wrote this
somebody donated two bucks and said andy
dick is talking [ __ ] about you on his
live right now oh well i'm sure it's all
i'm going off of right now okay well
check discord if you guys find it we'll
we'll pull it up during the show oh and
by the way somebody donated three
hundred dollars as a super chat and just
said peace and love to the pod squad and
all the food patrols
[Applause]
and i missed this one too i apologize
another 100 donation from son of jaren
i'll be your sponsor today shouts out to
zach big nasty boy
[Applause]
shouts out to you my friend thank you
son of jaren and ruby for those thank
you guys
very generous
yeah
do we have sponsors next week or next
month yes
okay that's good
i get worried when
like this week we had like one no we
have a healthy amount next week okay
that's great that's good news but thank
you guys so much that's nice
i had some on leftovers but somebody had
to go get covered
oh
oh
i did hear that there was an outbreak at
coachella so i mean of course there was
yeah
adds up
yo somebody said he streams with ice
poseidon's crew
yeah
that tracks his
oh from starring on a number one rated
sitcom to uh which one what do they
start on that's awesome the uh andy dick
show it was like a big mtv uh
like oh he had that too i was thinking
of a news radio oh well look he was
always a be comedian and the dude hasn't
been in [ __ ] in decades it's incredible
that the only reason people actually
know who he is is because
he's like a prolific
predator apparently
apparently his ex-girlfriend speaks out
about him here's our article about it
speaks out about his arrest i don't know
sounds like a great solid guy there's a
video clip of him getting body slammed
by an uber driver that's pretty good oh
no
[Laughter]
people are saying hassan said he did not
get covered from coachella he got it
from somewhere else oh okay well we'll
have to get the scoop when he comes
literally lying
[Laughter]
maybe somebody that he was with reached
out to him and said
i'm infected and that's why he tested oh
maybe yeah
that's right
that's right
it's like he's here andy dick arrested
for hitting his boyfriend in the head
with a liquor bottle
nice
here let me see if i can find andy dick
arrest record
andy dick arrest records here let's
let's pull up the hole and probably find
the one that i was talking about that
happened like a few days after he was at
my house oh he got charged for it
uh oh i see i see what you mean you're
not the one that happened at the house
yeah no no no
okay let's pop his wikipedia page
i like that i'm already prepping for
warren i don't even know what the [ __ ]
he said but
some people are saying he was in the
chat just trying to self-promote
and our chat yeah andy dick is in our
chat so
you know he's half of us so
well we're talking about him now
2008 july yeah
this this isn't good promo now yeah
i like facetimed with him one time
because wait what he had an interaction
with my dad and he was [ __ ] up and
like he like started hitting on my mom
no way yeah yeah like and he's like my
dad bought him a drink and
he hit my dad up for money
facetime like this i think i have his
number in my phone or something call him
right now
what is this you have andy dick's number
if i think i might still have it yeah
oh boy arrests and legal actions
in 1999 dick was questioned
is that it kind of ironic that his last
name is dick
it is yeah no it's great it is very
ironic
man
he's a dick
so
if zach has his number that's that's
kind of nuts
i don't have it in my contacts anymore
but i'm going to reach out to my brother
who might still have it
well there you go hopefully that clip
services because i really want to uh
i really want to see that
um
so basically there's a new theory going
around
by the way this guy's really good he um
he's on tick tock and i i love his
content he goes to like trump rallies
and plays it real straight and asks them
questions and these people are just
goblins
i feel bad in a way because these are
good these they seem like nice people
and they're it's just sad that they
get caught up
in this cult but
is he
like not to start drama but is he biting
andrew a little bit
oh this guy's been around for a while no
no
it's a diff the vibe is totally
different
trump plus jfk jr
is what his shirt says that man is red
boy
the guy that's doing the stand-up job of
trying to wake people up is an actor
wearing a mask i mean there's several
different people playing joe biden at
this point and when when he fell up the
stairs going on the airplane
i myself think that that was jim carrey
i've heard that he was one of them
wait wait wait wait you think that
jim carrey was wearing a mask
and
was the acting president really and
being silly but falling up the stairs
three different times
and james wood
i think is one of the
doppelganger mask wearing
people you think by
well
actually i saw that jim carrey responded
to that
that was jim
so this is the guy jason
selvig
the good liars that's i want to promote
them the good liars on tick tock
is where i consume their content they're
really good
actually what's the most important issue
in the governor's race here in virginia
getting back to the basics of teaching
children not teaching them critical race
theory
and uh and what is critical race theory
well i'm not going to get into the
specifics of it because i don't
understand it that much but it's
something that i don't know
what little bit that i know i don't care
for and and what have you heard that you
don't well i'm not i'm i'm not gonna
you know
i don't uh
i don't put him
that's so interesting i don't i don't
have that much knowledge on it but it's
something but i know it but i know i
hate it i know i hate it i know what i
hate and i know what i like
and i hate that critical race theory
yeah so he does a lot of stuff like this
it's really good um
kind of depressing
kind of sad i think it's tick tock if
that's easier
oh yeah let me yeah actually let's look
at some i really like his content i'm
getting a little promo here he's doing
good work he's doing god's work
the good liars on tick tock it sounds
like you were just turned away from the
here i'll just look at the real biden is
not alive right now
my name is ralph revant and i'm running
for the governor of michigan i'm a
pastor but i'm running on bringing god
back into culture because i'm convinced
that if we don't get god right in this
next election nothing will matter
bringing god back to michigan um what
would that look like would there be
religion taught in schools
uh there would be
as our founders said the bible should be
the basic textbook in scripture i mean
in schools are there books that you
don't want to see in schools
uh i would remove the pornography so we
need to ban we need to ban books that
have pornographic
imagery in them right
yes yes because because we somebody was
telling us about a book that had like
two daughters getting their dad drunk
and having sex with them yeah i knew
you're going that way i know you're
doing it yeah that's a good point you're
saying
ban the bible in school
uh no i'm not saying ban the bible in
school i i get where you're going with
your questions because it's because it's
uh you're saying anything that has a
pornographic image should be banned and
that there are some images in the bible
about you know sex and incest and things
like that so
it sounds like you're saying we should
ban the bible
uh
what i am saying is that the
judeo-christian principles on which our
country is founded need to be brought
back into culture and i i can't say it
anymore clearly than that um that means
spending the bible soviet
the bible would not be banned from
culture
or from the schools i'm just saying the
schools protect kids
these people are going on like a mad
tear banning books
you know don't say gay
it's having it's like a deep culture
issue now and it's like any book that
depicts any
thing uh
educational about sex or
uh sexuality of any kind it's like bam
[ __ ] bam
well it's like yeah it's a great point
you know
hey i'm here outside of planned
parenthood on a saturday morning where a
bunch of anti-abortion protesters have
signs and are trying to stop people from
getting abortions i'm gonna go join them
no no no the traffic the people really
gonna protest
no no no you guys do whatever you want
are you guys headed out yes it's
unfortunate that this
one sign can ruin a protest
wow well now it's just me
that's true that is kind of impressive
yeah these guys are great i'm telling
you they're
they're hard working too yeah who would
you rather have this [ __ ] joe biden or
vladimir putin oh putin
definitely and and why is that um i
believe he's been given a tough uh
since since world war ii uh russia's
been the bad guy
when in actuality the nazis left germany
and they ended up going to the ukraine
coming in here george bush was actually
thank you george bush was actually a
nazi who would you rather
that that might be true
but like i mean this is the this is the
conservative there's like a fringe
conservative movement that is
pro-putin
and i think i just find it really funny
when you have elon musk tweeting out
these memes about
the left moving and it's like here you
have someone literally saying i wish
putin was the president not biden
vladimir putin that's true
but there you go the good liars
went on a tangent there
um i found the number if you want to
okay how should we do this because uh
technically we can't air
i don't think it's kosher to air no
let's are we talking seriously no don't
well you come
whoa step away and call him i could try
to get him to call into the show just
like yo i sent it to a b because
just step away
so so we can't hear you're gonna step
over there and say hey andy i'm on a
street podcast ethan klein would you
like to call in
we heard you were talking [ __ ]
he's like do you want to call him is he
in front of yours no he's not a friend
of mine come on just give it a ring
what's the worst it's probably i bet you
it's not his number there's no
shot that number but he was saying that
his number is public saying his number's
public wait his number's public yeah he
just posted it on twitter or something
apparently
he probably gets a bajillion calls from
people harassing him yeah is it not one
of those weird marketing things it might
be
the number i have for him is different
than the one he posted do it do it do it
do it just go over there so we can't
hear if he answers
so we're not breaking the law just call
him i can't get up okay i'll call him oh
my god i'll call him
i can do it i mean i would do it if i
wasn't live i'll call him i'll call him
do you want me to do it maybe just to
turn his mic off dan
okay so if he's going to call the number
so let's see what happens
not here right you gotta watch i don't
think okay yeah okay so abs so
thank you
okay so
it's rain game
okay so the numbers ring game
um
[Music]
let's see is it ringing maybe
it's not even ranking
it went straight to voicemail and he
said leave your number
he said yeah it's uh his voicemail said
leave your number but you don't even
know if it's his number
i mean it's his voice oh it's oh what's
wrong with his voice yeah oh so he okay
so it's actually his number fake number
though like the marketing stuff i've had
this for
probably five years based on the stories
oh zach actually has his number though
that's crazy
so maybe call back and leave a message
say hey we're live on the issue podcast
uh
we heard you're talking mad [ __ ]
so let's [ __ ] do this do we even know
if that's true it was just this random
chatter
well we weren't able to find any
evidence well we're trying to confirm
that
yeah yeah well we heard and so let's i
mean it's interesting you gotta go to
the source right
right
we're just we're doing reporting
we're after the truth
for the truth found it for the truth
baby
so
abe is strutting around
what do you where he go in the bathroom
or something he doesn't want us to hear
i do need to go to the bathroom
so okay that would be interesting
so we got some new alpha male um
quickly
alpha male advice alpha official
love this guy
he's giving us advice on how to avoid
leaving a pee mark after you go to the
oh my bathroom
i dribbled that's awkward if you're a
dude you this is how
um
yeah you were saying it's too deep of a
stain right like that's a lot of urine i
you left the message
what did you say
i left a message said we're trying to
reach out to him from the h3 podcast we
heard he was talking about us please
give us a call back okay very
professional
[Music]
you didn't bring up any of the
accusations zach misses him
yeah
okay
well let's see
it'll be interesting
he's gonna call you tonight and just
like
somehow end up hanging out with you dude
he's gonna call you at four in the
morning and hit you up for a ride or
some [ __ ] i'll tell them to come
tomorrow
my friend has a show tomorrow we could
go together oh okay right all right
oh yeah is you talk zach you have your
show tomorrow yeah are you want to you
want to plug it
uh yeah tomorrow night live with the
mint uh april 30th 9 pm
live at the mint uh ticket links are in
my social media bios and um paid event
paid event yeah are you getting paid uh
yeah yeah yeah can i call them out now
or after the vet
call them after after okay
you don't want andy dick there
no i don't want andy dick there kind of
hype
no he'll he'll ruin there's even a
family guy bit about andy dick showing
up and like it [ __ ] everything up well
that's exciting you've got a paid event
yeah it's fun good for you buddy thank
you thank you it's you know it's not
like insane it's just i'm up there to
just play oh yeah and uh
yeah share share the love of music
absolutely who doesn't love music yeah
yeah
especially played by savon i appreciate
that thank you all right alpha male 1 oh
my oh my god
i tripled that's awkward if you're a
dude this has happened right the dribble
what do you do it always happens at the
worst time what i've come to realize is
if i go commando it's going to happen
100 of the time unless of course what i
don't understand is why is he going
commando
why don't what's your reason for not
wearing underwear especially with jeans
that just seems like rough business yeah
no it's not not advisable yeah i'm not
taking a paw speaking of something about
mary that's what i'd be afraid of
zipping myself up if i wasn't wearing
underwear right
i'm worried about leaving about getting
pit i mean this exact reason
but it seems just ungodly not to wear
underwear is he trying to show off his
package or something so there's like a
deeper outline like what's the reason
for going commando what actually is the
reason for not wearing underwear you'd
freak
do you know what i'm saying i think the
only reason not to wear underwear is to
try to show off his package line more
i have no idea i see no benefit
yeah so eli this is alpha male advice on
how to avoid getting pee stains on your
pants okay i'll replay it for you from
there oh my
oh my god
i dribbled that's awkward if you're a
dude this has happened right the dribble
what do you do it always happens at the
worst time what i've come to realize is
if i go commando it's going to happen
100 of the time unless of course there's
your answer don't go commando you weirdo
commando means no underwater yeah
it's psychotic yeah
also
wait so what is he suggesting you know
if you don't wear underwear your pants
get all stinky too because you're like
farting and your balls stink
just from like sweat not like from not
showering i'm not talking about crotch
rock [ __ ] like the quarter talking about
that crotch rock i'm just saying it
don't smell good in there and if you
don't wear pants if you don't wear
underwear your pants are going to absorb
that smell you know you get that crotch
rod no i don't that's not what i'm
referring
get done doing your business and before
you put the horse back in the stable you
plot it right that's a way for you not
to actually have a pea stain if you're
going commander now if you're wearing
underwear one two three four possibly
five then anything more than that you're
playing with it and then tap it on your
underwear before you get finished doing
your business
i don't understand why you need a video
for this
you say he said if you don't want to pee
stain what you want to do is shake the
urine off your penis
was he suggesting to wipe it on your
underwear yeah that's what he said this
isn't what he's saying wait i thought he
wasn't wearing underwear well he said if
you do though if you do
wait let me let me read that again if
you're wearing underwear one two three
four possibly five then anything more
than that you're playing with it and
then tap it on your underwear before you
get finished doing your best oh yeah
he's saying put the p on your underwear
i mean i it's yeah i don't know
tough response with 20k likes who goes
commando with jeans it's psychotic bro
why just videos
this is alpha [ __ ] dude
i can't get enough of these alpha males
never be a beta
that's all i know never be a beta self
is [ __ ] to piss yourself
nothing more alpha than just [ __ ]
pissing all over your jeans yeah real
alpha just pee his [ __ ] pants like a
big boy and just
stare at the person you're conversing
with right in the eyes that's dominance
bro straight up i'd be scared if someone
did that
dribble dominance
here's the alpha pro tip pro tip to how
to adjust in public and pocket in right
just little little little yep ah right
there you're i'm sorry but
are still wet from the other tick tock
wait wait nowhere
wait hold on hold on this is a
hang on hang on hang on the alpha and
pro tip to how to adjust in public and
pocket oh my god
he's still got the dribble
my dude you've got the [ __ ] piece
thing great observation is he seriously
wearing his jacket like that or is this
a joke no this guy's serious this alpha
business is crazy
the guy is like this the whole
conversation is not alpha you're worried
about digesting your junk and [ __ ] just
grab your [ __ ] and move it bro be alpha
are you jerking off what are you doing
yep ah right there you're good right
nobody saw anything all right that's the
alpha and pro tip the how to work he's
kind of talking about what we were
talking about earlier in the show to be
honest
i don't think he's talking about having
an erection he's talking about adjusting
your [ __ ] what i feel like he's talking
about it in a serious way so
that means he's assuming his audience
like 15 years old
oh no no no
please god
there's another one for him
oh this one we just watched oh my god
so did you make like 30 tick tocks in
one day my breath now we gotta talk
about boobs because they literally are
like we're gonna talk about boobs you
guys yeah i think you might be right
here you just can't every audience yo
out my alpha males we're going to talk
about boobs today
kind of gross send me out this guy
dude
now we gotta talk about boobs because
they literally are like a magnet rolling
our male eyes towards them how are you
gonna not look like a creepy weirdo
always staring at her boobies what i
would recommend if you have a difficult
time making eye contact are you serious
see some titties you need a tips and
tricks to not look at titties
i mean that may be helpful to some
people i suppose
i mean out of all these alpha guys i
find this like this guy i find less
objectionable oh i doubt it no you don't
think so i get creepy vibes oh
interesting okay but like i have a
creepy radar all right you think that's
fair the radar is dangling but what
about like compared to guys who are like
fresh and fit who are like we need to
make sure that women can't leave their
house with right exactly or like they
shouldn't you you need your passwords i
don't want to say anything i don't know
about him but i'm just saying i'm good
you get the vibes okay the bad vibes
fair enough yeah
it's the making content for kids yes and
like maybe they hit him up in the dms i
don't know oh sh
oh
whoa
ela is a good dar
the dark eliza almost an infallible
creep dark hmm
[Music]
all right i'll defer to your judgment
i wasn't saying that i like him by the
way i was just saying like dan you're
going to hit him up in the dms like
compared to uh yeah
and like those kind of guys seems more
light-hearted versus the we need to we
need to alpa we need to make sure that
women have no anatom control over their
bodies right like fresh and fit we're
like trying to turn
trying to make like sharia law here or
something
contact with the spicy sanjorita look at
her forehead right here gentlemen right
above her eyes and this is a lot more
i'm sorry but what the [ __ ] just look at
her eyes why do you got to look at her
forehead to avoid staring at her tits
and then you're weird like can you tell
i'm looking at your forehead right now
i i yeah it feels like you're looking at
my hair or something yeah
he's like just stare at their forehead
instead of their boobs what the [ __ ]
advice is that people for a lot of guys
when it comes to making eye contact if
you're somebody that really has a
difficult time making eye contact
because you are a little bit shy or it's
just uncomfortable for you why is he
shouting at them their eyes is as
effective because you can't tell the
difference and we got to talk about how
is that advice
stare at their forehead so you don't
look at their boobs just look at their
eyes what the [ __ ]
what
it's crazy
you want more yellow no i don't wait
this one has a lot of views i love
stinky balls which brings us to the next
biggest grooming mistake you guys are
still not powdering your junk after you
get out of the chicken
wait this guy's it's like his whole
channel is talking about your junk he's
talk he i think his audience
is
young man yeah like not like
18 plus no because who's going to be
like how do i not look at boobs
i feel like he's making more of this
content for tick-tock because his
youtube videos at least the ones i've
seen don't seem to be this uh
this crazy
right
well this guy is about to tell all guys
they need to powder their balls every
day so bet so buckle up
i love stinky balls which brings us to
the next biggest grooming mistake you
guys are still not powdering your junk
after you get out of the shower you
towel dry and then boom a little bit of
that down there up the booty crack
because swamp ass every single one of
you even you brian right should be
powdering big alan the boys prior to
leaving the house it's going to keep you
dryer it's going to keep you smelling
amazing and so and that spicy sand you
read is like yo daddy i want to go say
hey to al right you're like yo get it
girl because i know i smell amazing
no no no i gotta say
this is bad advice you do not want your
junk smelling like baby powder that's
disgusting pretty weird
i don't know
whoa
i don't know
why going out and buying powder after
that like oh [ __ ] that's probably a good
idea and they buy powder so so here's
the thing when i started getting fat my
thighs started rubbing together so i
heard that if you use baby powder it can
help with the chafing
but the thing is it sweat and baby
powder
it turns to like flour you're basically
you're kneading dough down there
no it's not good smell man holy [ __ ]
there you have it alpha male sigma uh
this is alpha energy
trying to look for his viral ones
plus one
five pounds in the next 30 days what
you're gonna notice is something
interesting by simply losing five pounds
a lot of the times we hold a lot of
weight in our face and that is the place
in the area that you notice at first
your cheeks will become more defined
your cheekbones more pronounced and your
jaw stronger you're somebody that is
carrying a little bit more body fat guys
i would shoot for like eight pounds i
want you to lose five there you go guys
it's 30 days
let's get that gaunt look
let's get that gaunt look boys
to just give that blanket advice not
knowing about anyone's health conditions
because if you're super skinny that
could be dangerous
yeah but apparently he's got
six million subbies
and he was on shark tank yeah
no wait what was his product
it was from what i see a 300
wardrobe dvd that teaches you basically
oh bro you trying to sell dvd
he's trying to sell dvd with the year
yeah what year is that
it is season four shark tank
i don't want to get in there
shark tank alpha m he still went by
alpha m
we do we're mocked and ridiculed
okay yeah well nothing's changed
oh my god
tell me they did not give him a deal so
the video cuts before them but the
comments are saying that all the sharks
turn them down thank you ain't nobody
invested in a dvd dude
300 dvd of how to dress just watch whoa
um
what is this a footage of idubbbz boxing
oh you you really want to talk about
this okay i love this this is my
favorite video ever to the body then
back upstairs yes now back upstairs our
[ __ ] day there all [ __ ] day yes i
love you let's go baby let's go body
body mickey's body rip his body rip this
body then back upstairs
[ __ ] yes
[Music]
what what what did you want to say about
it baby
it speaks for itself it's just legendary
i love how at one point when he's
screaming [ __ ] him up [ __ ] him up he
goes i love you
he did say that yeah yeah you didn't
catch it i love you
that's kind of the opposite approach
you're a coach yeah definitely different
but michael's the man and i also want to
say that uh so people aren't surprised
because a lot of people they loved
wall-e on the last episode unfortunately
he's unable to attend the actual fight
because of uh something to do with his
travel visa but
uh michael the guy screaming that was
the wrong button he's going to be your
boy it's going to be in my corner yeah i
love you
upstairs i love you i love you
what about vin diesel
upstairs yes ian does look powerful
though yeah his arms look big
yeah all [ __ ] days
all [ __ ] day yes i love you
i love you interesting technique i love
you yo i wanna [ __ ] you dog
[Laughter]
you look good right now
i want to [ __ ] you all day dog
oh baby let's go body body mickey's body
what's in this box this is fine
you just let somebody in like oh did he
is that what's going on yeah
he did
yo how do you walk into it just walk
into that
oh my god that guy's multitasking yeah i
like that
he's the man okay [ __ ] yes let's go
apparently this was like the last round
round six so that's pretty impressive
right yeah definitely
oh that's round six round six leicester
who is you fighting there i think just
someone's borrowing with someone at the
gym i'm guessing a pro because he's not
wearing any headgear or uh yeah he
didn't seem too concerned
there was they posted one of uh ian
getting clocked
oh yeah
actually if the video we were just
watching the first when it first starts
it's like the meanest hook i've ever
seen ian gets clocked in the face
i'll go back and watch it right here
[Laughter]
and posting ls on their own thing which
is that's what you know hey props right
i think
uh where's the one i was looking at
and got he got a buffed
it's in the
dock
yeah that first one that was mean
oh yeah
well you gotta get used to it right yeah
dr mike is a big tough guy
so i love you
i love you man
okay oh speaking of tip talk so this is
my i have a special tik tok account that
i've fallen in love with yeah
this guy is unbelievable this is my
special find
i've been tracking this guy's page
because i just couldn't believe what i'm
seeing so he is a criminal defense
attorney
and he gets people off for really [ __ ]
up crimes
and then he goes and brags about it on
tick tock
you'll see what i mean
i i think this might have been the first
one i saw and i was like what
i was like
[Music]
what the [ __ ] here watch this
all right we're outside of rancho
cucamonga courthouse with my amazing
client we're here on a third time dui
case that we totally crush
there's a mandatory minimum of 120 days
county jail for this kind of case
they offered us 310 days jail on this
case and they weren't budget
but today we got no jail no jail at all
case closed zero jail aren't you happy
you forgot to bring your two away
really glad i didn't need a toothbrush
we don't need it no we're good let's go
you so much i appreciate you 100
you're the man
let's go
oh my god
yo
she's on her third dui uh she's supposed
to go to jail for a year but what we did
we got her off zero jill it's a freezing
gang also the other weird thing is that
he's like kind of putting them on black
yeah like publicly humiliating them for
his own practice
third dui and california carries a
mandatory minimum of 120 days here the
prosecutor offered us 310 days we fought
hard and secured a deal with zero jail
time baby
chad's saying the real life salt goodman
exactly
totally honestly this guy's even less
tactful than saul with the way he's like
like saul knows how to keep it like
like classy on the surface you know like
look at this [ __ ] domestic violence
two domestic violence cases consolidated
into trespassing big dubs check it out
all right we're right look at that big
smile
he's like this man just killed his wife
and today i'm happy to say he got
probation he's moving in with his new
girlfriend
downtown l.a with my great client here
it was falsely alleged against him that
he committed domestic violence against
the mother of his child on one day and
it was also falsely alleged again that
he did it two and a half months later
this was two domestic violence cases
consolidated into one
and we just resolved the case what did
we resolve it for what was the
conviction first question trespassing
we were fighting this case for about
seven to eight months we announced ready
for trial on this case we're ready to go
forward and beat the charges and i'm
pleased to announce that
once once he's done with probation it's
going to be gone off his record once we
expunge it
how you feel i feel great appreciate you
let's go
god
he's
like my life still sucks you know
i love this guy man he's the [ __ ]
greatest
here we go i like how he makes him
participate what did we get exactly
they don't want to be put on out there
like this man beat his wife three times
what was your name
this one goes uh second time dui with
alcohol and cocaine
150 dale days of jail reduced to zero oh
my god my man
all right we just got out of court in
beautiful
beach we're here on a second time dui my
great client here
uh was pulled over he had doubled the
legal limit he was actually at .18 blood
alcohol content he had 13 nanograms of
cocaine in his blood he found an
empty vial of that also
he was looking at 150 days of county
jail out here
and we just crushed it he's going to do
how much jail oh none
zero jail
let's go
and after a year he's gonna be all done
with this case and he can move on with
his life yeah thank you so much i
appreciate the the help
and the work that's put in
it's great
i wonder if it's in like the contract
they signed that you have to make a tick
tock at the end with him i think i think
they're
they're i don't know man maybe maybe
yeah i think what he does
if you let me uh put you on blast
i think what he does is he's just like
oh there's one thing i want to do real
fast yeah and then they're stuck there
yeah
for a second i was like what if he's
just joking what if this is all just
stick um no i looked it up he passed his
bar no he's real yeah
no there's a lot of them he does this
like every day
so
let's see another domestic abuse uh case
all right we're right outside of court
in india it's 106 degrees we're here on
a domestic violence restraining order uh
my great client here
uh was accused of many many instances of
domestic violence many many many
great tried to get a restraining order
well i'm very proud to announce he's a
free man
oh my god
this is the best this is not the
craziest [ __ ] you're the greatest ever
it's cons they're all false his ex
perjured herself like crazy
one by one we attacked each accusation
and in the end what happened
none of them are true man thrown away
let's go okay
let's go
let's go well if i ever get charged with
crime i know who
i'm i know who i'm hiring
miss let's go we got to get his face on
the sign just being like let's go let's
go
you know like
criminal defense lawyers that's a
that's a very valuable thing in society
and like you know it is all right people
deserve to all right
i'm sorry why the [ __ ] tick tock start
auto playing audio now when it's small
it's just tick tock sucks okay go up
sorry i'm just saying like
the you know
what's so abhorrent about this though is
just like
the the bragging like that's it
braggadocious attitude about getting
these people off
some of these are weird i feel like
there's even worse ones like look at
this but also so unaware like he's
accused of many many many
great clients
look at this one killed the mother of
his child but we're celebrating
yo look at this one four years prison
suspended for felony probation violation
reduced to four months rehab
all right we're right outside of san
fernando courthouse what's the weather
today client's wife uh my client was
convicted of a crime and had four years
of prison suspended so any more
violations during probation and he would
go away to prison for four years
automatically
last time we were in court about a week
ago the judge indicated that he wanted
to send him away for the four years
we did some work up on the case and
today we had a deal with the judge where
my client her husband will be able to go
to a rehab program for about four to six
months and then he'll be free
how do you feel i feel good i feel that
doesn't sound too bad
i like that yeah i mean that one was
less objectionable
i love all the
here here's another domestic abuse one
great day today in court
we're about to start a jury trial today
we have the jurors waiting for us
outside and she was accused of domestic
violence against her
father of her child
and look he lied so much in this case
and he was just turning her life upside
down with these accusations he was even
going to family court
filed a request for full custody two
requests two restraining orders that
were dismissed and then for full time
yeah we we beat those right
this med season wasn't so incredible
so
you know he's probably still in court
right now trying to convince the d.a to
to go forward with the jury trial that's
not going forward how do you feel david
is so amazing like he god sent him to me
to represent me praise god david will
fight for you
he truly cares about his clients and he
and if he always answers his phone so
thank you so much david all right praise
god let's go
you see the top comment and his response
i can fix her what was it no it was like
i can charge her and then he responded
with like a crying laughing emoji great
date i can change her oh change her yeah
yeah yeah thank you wait what
today it's just one it's something like
great day you got like this
day today
well there's actually not that many so i
think one too all right we're right
outside of van nuys courthouse yo this
is awesome
he was charged with a second time dui
he has more on his instagram i'm
watching through them right now okay let
me know if there's any good ones
so the top comment on this one is no
keep this man off the road for life so
you know it's good here we go all right
we're right outside of van nuys
courthouse i got my great client here he
was charged with the second time dui
uh he admittedly overdosed on multiple
different oh this this is i think this
is the one i saw because it's like he
admits to it i got it he did all this
and we got him back on the road
my great client here he was charged with
a second time dui
uh he admittedly overdosed on multiple
different drugs that night because of
drug induced psychosis he crashed with
two other cars
i can't
i'm just looking at his face
this man ran over a whole family on the
highway
he was blackout drunk tested positive
for pcp
he was gonna go to jail for life and we
got him out on bond ladies and gentlemen
no jail time
reduced to 10 to 10 months of community
service
and he got his license restated
huge
all the comments are no keep this man
off the road
bro is unleashing super villains send
this man back to jail
it's the worst one by far
oh and this comment this is what i was
laughing at he said the bro oh my god
bro is standing there like yeah i did
all that
like watch homies face who he who he got
off like holy [ __ ] dude
this is the best one
courthouse i got my great client here he
was charged with a second time dui
uh he admittedly overdosed on multiple
different drugs that night get him
causing drug induced psychosis he
dragged him out of the car and started
fighting with them
[Laughter]
punching her
let's see how we let's see
let's see how he gets him off
oh my god this is the best
so
um
and we're pleased to announce that he's
getting out of this with just a wet
reckless
wet reckless that's a ryan cavanagh
that's the right
move right
yo what he's like he went in the full
psychosis overdosed on multiple drugs
caused a major wreck on the freeway
hit two other cars and he fought with
the police
and the firefighters
it's just a wet and reckless guys we're
very proud to announce that here today
here's your license buddy get back on
the road
cheers a probation not five years that
is normally given in a second time dui
and most importantly he's really changed
his life around he put himself in rehab
immediately after this happened he's
been in for nine months he does meetings
every single day and he's really turned
his life around how you feeling i'm
feeling great thank you so much lady for
everything i've done
[Music]
to me that sounds like straight menace
like that man should not be able to
drive again
i'm sorry
oh
holy [ __ ] dude
oh that was [ __ ] right outside
we're right outside of torrance
courthouse uh we're here today on a case
that was actually two cases put together
possession of meth for sales
gets bailed out four months later gets
caught for the same exact thing
and
okay
is he trying to make them like this man
is a serial meth dealer
he's got a hustle hat on
i took this case with intention of
taking the case to jury trial and we're
going to try the case in april but kovit
happened and we haven't been able to do
that
this is the best deal i have ever seen
in my entire career
after he does a sober living program he
will get a felony dismissed
in as if the case never happened
all right and he's going to be able to
live the rest of his life as if this
never happened and he'll have his life
back how do you feel amazing i got my
life back dave's amazed man he saved my
life um i couldn't ask for more let's go
i'm very thankful i feel blessed
thank you of course
let's go
this guy's i'm sorry but who are you
this guy's unreal
i mean i guess it's good marketing for
what he does right
totally
you know
he's
good at his job evidently
all right we just we saw this one
all right we're right out outside of
court i'm with my great client here he
was charged with committing a dui
uh on top of that the police falsified
the report and accused him of admitting
to doing donuts in a parking lot
uh he then allegedly crashed into a pole
hurt himself thank god no one else was
hurt and thank god it wasn't too serious
went to the hospital but we just took a
deal today
we're gonna have the dui charges
dismissed
and he just took a reckless driving
which is so crucial because instead of
three years of probation with a dui he's
only going to have probation for one
year after he's done with probation we
could file for an expungement and clean
his record like it never happened how
you feel the one thing i hate about this
like i'm anti-crim like jail but duis
are you if you get more than one dui you
should never drive period ever
so this like three-time dui we got his
license back that shit's [ __ ] oh my
gosh what a relief you know so much
david david you've helped me out
immensely here can't thank you enough my
man really let's go celebrate wait i
want to hear the let's go right outside
i'm with my let's go grab a drink
[Laughter]
my pleasure thank you man all right
let's go
let's go oh too much wine sorry do you
find anything good on instagram maybe no
i i feel like nothing could top the ones
we've already seen oh i [ __ ] i didn't
find that one client got a tattoo of his
phone number because he was so gracious
wow get a discount that was a good
question
should yeah all right we're right
outside of court we got an excellent
result today on a dui case my great
client here caused a traffic accident
with a few parked cars he was eventually
found to have
double the legal limit of blood alcohol
at first he refused doing the alcohol
test so the police had to get a warrant
to force a blood draw
so he came to court and he was charged
with enhancements for having such a high
blood alcohol content for refusing the
blood alcohol test and he was looking at
losing his license for a year
without the ability to even get a
restricted license i'm really happy to
announce that today we got him an
excellent deal no enhancements
literally as low as you can go in terms
of punishment for a dui and he's he's
back to driving and we're all good to go
how do you feel feel great man
appreciate it
i love that he's back to driving man did
you hear what you just said you shared
the roads with these people
just a few parked cars is all yet just a
couple yeah
this man is doing a public disservice
holy [ __ ]
he's in here commenting too he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he just said no
oh god
great stuff right right outside of court
we got an excellent result today on a
deep
[ __ ] incredible oh here he is at
coachella bonus meme
let's see his fit let's rate the fit
just the suit you're keeping it real all
right i just finished up with court and
i'm walking to my car i'm gonna get
started heading to coachella who's
coming
hit me up no my god all right i just
he's gonna meet a lot of clients there
right
hit me up is he talking to like if
you're if you like need a lawyer he's
looking for friends i know you're
looking for friends or clients
friends that will turn into clients
friends and clients there's no
difference
i wonder what's his
hourly rate
are you gonna hire him for the some of
the lawsuits
i don't think he's a litigator seems
more of a
i don't know what you call what he does
man
he specializes in getting people off dui
as it seems like and domestic violence
well there you have it guys
there you have it if you get if you get
uh drug-induced psychosis and
crash into a bunch of vehicles he's your
guy punch a cop and flip a car and
attack a cop he's your guy
that's awesome man lopez of law
hmm
interesting
who wants me to take their money
all right fresh and fit
we got new fresh and fit cringe
yeah um
we should tell our stories too
yeah that's kind of what i'm wondering
because i know you guys have a heart out
today and i wanted to get to the
storytelling thing so oh god i'm sorry
you know i started taking the wellbutrin
and i was so excited about it now
it's making you itch i had to stop
taking it because i got like a rash
and i'm like itchy all over my [ __ ]
body
my arms my butt like the side of my butt
cheeks my now it's on my face that's
like a known side effect of it no it's
not it's like
a super rare weird side effect
i called my doctor this morning
and he told me to stop taking it it
could be he we could try a different
generic of the drug or the name brand of
the drug but
i'm all itchy now
i'm sorry to hear that i don't know if
it's that or something else but nothing
has changed
i do i just googled wellbutrin itching
skin and there is a lot of stuff about
it so i just saw that what about wraps
yeah it specifically says that
call your doctor right away if you have
a rash itching swelling on the face
tongue so that's what we did yeah
so yeah it sounds like you had a
reaction to it
that's unfortunate you were all very
excited about it well hopefully one of
the other ones will work because
i'm just going to be fat forever
speaking of which tgi fridays
you ever had a perfectly you ever had a
perfectly layered nacho
no
used to go to tgi fridays uh
to uh hang out after
serving shifts all the time there was
like one right down the street didn't
maybe didn't you say you did the same
thing back in the day
we used no at cedar point we used to it
was like the only restaurant that was at
this amusement park so we'd always go
hey won't we visit there yeah well you
would get off your server shift and go
to tgo spend all of our tips at another
restaurant what the [ __ ] yeah terrible
terrible strategy why would you do that
because you i mean you worked in a
restaurant right you know how it was
right
oh [ __ ] no they would not give us free
drinks in my restaurant hell no yeah we
got we we're i mean it was really poorly
managed so like so yeah i worked at like
a corporate chain oh yeah no it wasn't
like that it was a restaurant at like a
high-end camping resort
and it was really really badly managed
so
we were eating like filet mignons for
free
pot roast drinks
actually sad i'm sad to say this but
someone got so [ __ ] up there one night
one of the servers he drove home and
[ __ ] died oh jesus yeah
so it was actually it's a really crazy
road to get there it's the one
the one from santa cruz so it's all
windy and [ __ ] up oh yeah that's wine
and this guy got oh yeah how drunk and
drove home after getting trashed at the
bar and he just flipped his [ __ ] car
going like 100 miles per hour yikes
that's horrible
you know i thought it was really weird
i'm not one to judge
grieving parents because i could only
imagine how how painful that was
but they had a memorial where he died
on on the one
where they asked all friends and family
to come and they had a and they threw a
kegger there
you're kidding no i swear to god they
brought a keg and everyone was drinking
no swear to [ __ ] god
you're not
no i'm not kidding i sand the [ __ ]
god they brought a keg
there to the side of the road where he
died you could see his [ __ ] blood
stained on the concrete stuff
and they brought a keg out oh the dog is
like beer yeah big ass keg of beer
that's what i say i look i'm not to i'm
not trying to judge parents who are
families
i don't know but i thought that was
pretty weird there's no right way to
doing
grieving so well
one is that everyone could be driving
home drunk because that's like remote
yeah exactly
they're like how bad do you miss him
who's trying to join him yeah brian
i mean it's it's notoriously one of the
most dangerous but in a way it's like
the kid loved to drink party i don't
know yeah i think that was their logic
i i don't know i feel like um i think it
was a family of alcohol it's kind of
like it kind of sucks out like we don't
ever talk about how like what to do
in that moment
and so it's like you don't know what to
do so i don't know maybe that's a good
thing well what if your son oh dude on
heroin and you're like let's shoot it up
shoot last one up for our boy
okay but i mean like beer is not heroin
but you have a cup of beer
no they were trashed
let's assume that the ones that were
drinking did not drive they did
by the way for your itchiness do you
want some uh
uh hydrocortisone no no
we don't think anything on the show
just suggested that to me is that what
blew me up last time yes
yeah that was super weird man
i went out there
you know it's a good 30 minutes from
town drive yeah and i went out with a
few of my other buddies who worked at
that restaurant
and
they his parents were there and they
[ __ ] had a whole keg and people had
red cups and i was like this is weird
i thought you were trolling i was just
no they were trashed and they were
drinking from a keg on the side of the
road it was [ __ ] weird
but that's it you know it's painful and
painful so
can only imagine
very painful
but there you have it
all right what's fresh and fit been up
to um
they received dozens of dms on instagram
letting them know that pokeman reacted
to their video
what did pokeys which which of their
videos did pokey react it was like an
old video it was the one that's going
viral about them saying uh if you're
dating someone they shouldn't have an
instagram for dating a girl right
it's cheating but he he said for a girl
to have instagram is cheating
that's what i'm saying these guys are
basically like
they're closer to isis than they are to
me in terms of like treating women i
swear to god
real quick
you're going to die uh andy dick just
followed me on instagram oh
no okay i just told him dm
i told him
what's happening did you actually say
hit up zach like no [ __ ]
i forget
just say what you said
okay no no me yeah no i'd say just call
us back yeah just call us back but he
knows what's going on but how does he
remember you i don't know that's so busy
so message him okay
oh my god this is so weird
i want him to call in sure
i'd like to know what he said first
did um
did nobody find him talking about us
he's he's the kind of guy who screamed
the n-word on like a live show okay so i
was about to type this out to you yeah
uh
i don't know about having him on live
he's like he's he's got nothing to lose
this man yeah yeah that's like he's
playing down really bad he sleeps on his
friend's couch he doesn't have a house
no
yeah let's import well let's let's chat
with him not live not no i don't we're
not going to take his live call because
he's untrustworthy yeah
but
but uh just type with him see if he
responds we can get a little chat going
yeah there's nothing he sleeps on ice
poseidon's couch
not eyes for that i'm not sure if you're
joking i was i made a logical leap there
all right
should we should we skip to our stores
because i don't know if we'll have time
for everything
well our heart out is we still have an
hour 10.
this
fresh and fit thing is
i could see it taking an hour to get
through but i love fresh
if it's taking too long
i just want to watch the video i see you
all got like stats and [ __ ]
i just let here we have the best moments
that ab put a lot of work into right
and dan helped me out this morning you
guys slaved over this best moment it was
there were so many good moments it was
hard to cut it down i'd have dan help me
with the final 30 minutes
so anyway she reacted to that clip we
all did i mean everybody was watching
that clip
he went on to react to her noting that
he wanted to attack her points not her
directly i go and look
am i is this just paraphrasing the video
yeah i want you to just click the link
pretty much
yeah
so here we go
the other day 13 minutes holy [ __ ] this
one
this is i mean this cut down from like
almost two hours i'm talking about it or
like an hour and a half or something so
is there patreon popping did we look
before and there was like nobody there
right
i honestly don't recall
oh check my script a lot of time you
can't and i
see how many subs people have on patreon
but i know they only charge 30 on cameo
for the both of them
that's less than all of us
well i don't think
coconuts and barbados gets paid
so it's a better deal 30 for both of
them we know that's like 10 bucks after
the fee right
between the two of them
all right
all right we got a hustle picking
coconut some barbados
it says it's so fast
play it again
you can coconut some barbados he says he
speaks fast
interesting
i get a bunch of dms pokemans reacting
to your stuff and i was like what is
that pokemon i was like is that a
pokemon whatever because
this guy pokemon gotta catch em all so
yeah
throughout this whole podcast
he does this the whole time this is his
comedy every time they say pokemane
that's how they got barbados he brought
his pokemon cards together good
epic that's so [ __ ] clever though
yeah
and insulting too because everybody
hates pokemon
pokemon pokemon cards
i go and i look and i see that she's
breaking down this old ass video of us
and i'm not gonna attack her personally
guys nah i'm just gonna attack her
arguments because the one thing that
stuck out to me guys is that she has a
very similar thought process to a lot of
the girls that come on this show all
right so uh let's pull up this clip
right here man this is her reacted to us
on an old video by the way
video production hue like shooting
directly into a sunny balcony
[ __ ] major dubs in terms of
production
that's the first thing i said and then
at night it reflects you can see the big
bright light i didn't this is like
awesome no curtains right you want that
sun going directly into the lens
that's a really even my mom knows not to
do that
it's great no it's really great we're
talking about using instagram
as a girl
is cheating chris you uh yeah i'm at it
again okay you got it for us yeah man it
is wednesday shout out to our guy
agentfit that helped us with making this
video
that should stop me in my tracks i was
like what
what
dude i cannot and that says
what are you are you having a
conversation with somebody else
are you guys even like happy
why are you even there dude
man
wednesday man it sure is buddy
it's so weird
who's fresh and i don't know who's fit
men and women are not the same we're not
the same at all can i get into a
nightclub for free just based on the way
i look yeah possible quick guys so i
want to establish this real fast because
a lot of these issues come from this one
one this one premise that women have
incorrect all the time thinking that men
and women are the same number one step
one quick note because it's not really
clear in the edit
at this point when he pauses it and then
goes on to uh to make this very good
point that he's about to make pokemane
has said nothing
not spoken literally all she said is i'm
not sure which one is fresh and which
one is finn that's all she said so he's
reacting to what he already talked about
in the original clip i guess awesome
but
no commentary yet
right
all human beings all human beings are
meant to procreate okay step three
there's two genders i know that sounds
crazy nowadays but there's two genders
guys men and women and each gender has a
different
mating strategy for men it's unlimited
sex with as many girls as possible right
unlimited sexualities we say with our
boy rolotomasi for women
oh shout out
hello
what are you genghis khan i don't
understand what you're saying
biologically
if you get as many women as pregnant
what are you a [ __ ] aunt i mean what
are you a moth
i mean dude we're [ __ ] we live in a
society it's 20 22. you don't need 20
kids bro just use what the [ __ ] trying
to send people to mars like are you
trying to colonize a new planet yeah
by the way raised by wolves yeah
i only watched one episode but very good
we watched two or two sorry but we just
i just finished severance i don't know
if you already talked about it we did a
bit i just said it was really good yeah
severance really good show yeah
um
these guys were raised by walls but it's
like they're like look biologically i'm
supposed to have sex with i'm supposed
to be promiscuous gonna have sex with as
many women as possible it's like man
just take responsibility you're just a
[ __ ] douchebag
you're just a sleazebag bro
you know what i'm saying
yo i need to repopulate mars
although i know you said you might have
a different definition but mine is
unlimited security with quality and then
fresh is like man it's a wednesday
wednesday man
you might have a different definition
than mine man it's wednesday right now
okay
so
men want the most women want the best
and if you guys think about it each
strategy
is kind of counter productive i don't
want the most
i'm not trying to do that speak for
yourself i want the best and i got it
hey
i'm not looking i don't you know what
i'm saying speak yeah speak for yourself
bro
gender in other words if a guy gets with
a girl right and he's monogamous what is
he doing he's suppressing his sexual
strategy if a woman [ __ ] a guy gets
with him and he doesn't provide security
that's her sexual strategy
i can't believe this show it's like you
know another planet
yeah it's like middle school philosophy
too because what he's saying is not
[ __ ] revolutionary or
exciting or fresh it's really it's
low-hanging fruit so pretty far from all
that yeah
on the head and like philosophy is the
best way to put it yeah it's but why
does he think that he's like there to
teach anybody something
i don't know he says that's his mission
his mission is to uh to educate men
he says
where did the knowledge come to him from
well as dan pointed out earlier when he
was watching the edit that the whole
thing is just a self-report somebody
definitely hurt him yeah he's projecting
no you'll see he's like his mom or just
the women that he's tried to date or
whatever because like he's always going
on about like they're going to make fun
of you they're going to laugh in your
face they're not going to want to date
you it's like that's you man like that's
that's i don't think a woman dating you
can [ __ ] you up this bad i think only a
parent can [ __ ] you up this bad bro
he always comes in like yeah it's
childhood trauma
i'm telling you i'm telling you you can
have a bad day you can have a really
wrong girlfriend but your only childhood
drama could make you hate women this
much
perhaps
what'd it be no you're saying he always
slips in uh you know girls always tell
you small dick energy like that somehow
always makes it in there
potentially a relationship but a
combination to be honest yeah
in my opinion
oops
some barbados
man the sun up the sun is up today man
it's a wednesday it's a sunny wednesday
someone has to concede in the
relationship typically here's the
problem though we live in a world now
where the females where is spoken saying
anything she hasn't said anything yet
that's what i'm saying by like as she's
just sitting there quietly in the midst
of this rant all she said is which one
is fresh and which one is that's all she
said man this [ __ ] is
crazy
respected more and upheld more and i'll
take it a step further we have economic
backing to strengthen the female sexual
strategy you don't believe me look at
the family courts look at the me too era
look at bro i can't even say hey we got
it you're doing he's got like a routine
it's like we get it
i gotta fast just fast when do you just
talk about pokemon
okay here
oh yeah that they're oppressed
they're not oppressed at all
because i can't think of one privilege
or right that a man enjoys that a woman
doesn't pretty much and well some of
y'all might say oh you might be able to
walk down the street and feel safer
that's the dumb ass argument i get from
the girls most the time uh well actually
men are far more likely to be the
victims of violent crime almost two to
three times as much a lot of violence
crime i don't think they're talking i
don't think we're talking about violent
like what a nice way to um shift the
status to
to justify what he's trying to say yeah
they're talking about sec they're
talking about essay bro
yeah
obviously
out there and think we're the same
and we're not
okay but they will not concede to the
fact that they get so many different
advantages and benefits as a woman that
a man will never enjoy
don't cut me off
right like
men can selfie pics too
you know what
if you are a guy
and um
if you're a man with petite feet
take advantage pause
i'm just saying the
mark you stupid
again i can't tell you i'm pretty sure
she's just making a joke yeah
you gonna record scratch that she didn't
even say anything about you dude uh
women biologically don't get to have
humor sense so
that's not impo that's not possible that
she was making a joke how are we going
to record scratch that
how many times i've had girls the porn
star that was on the show yesterday what
did she try to say oh i paid for porn
guys can make money on only fans
bruh
like i when women say this it is
disingenuous and it's not true when
girls try to say that like oh there's
girls thirsting on guys instagrams or
there's guys out there that make a lot
of money on only fans for smashing
chicks are there's guys out there that
pull chicks or whatever
dude what you are he's like arguing with
himself yeah just to point out
in 2021 five of the top 15 only fans
creators are guys
oh that that's that's crazy yeah we saw
this tyga
is actually one of the top he's like
number five number four
we saw on the list you know you know
who's in that top 15.
you know he was also in the top 15.
nicotto
whoa
no shut up which really runs counter to
his narrative because it's like yeah he
isn't like the ideal male body archetype
or anything like that nico carlos top
15. he's like number
uh it's uh there's a link to it in the
doc the list if you want to see
that's why i don't get anything this guy
is saying like it's not based on
anything in reality
none of it
what nicka cotto
yeah blac chyna bell thorn cardi b
tyga ya boy
mukwifa uh don't don't show the screen
careful careful
that bad
no it's not actually oh number one
here's a dude there's another guy nicki
minaj's ex
[Music]
yes what the [ __ ] oh he's ukrainian
shout out
i don't know that
um he remains
let me read the description um
if you subscribe to a celebrityonlyfans
account expecting more of the same you'd
be shockingly disappointed
the outrageous personality is still in
display but so is everything else and we
mean everything else
there you go
well if you're into whatever he's
offering you'd be very happy
because he like they said goes all out
whoa nicotto
what about bad babies she apparently
made like 50 million bucks that was this
year i'm not sure she was the right age
last year oh okay yeah
did you hear that she made fif she she
just the day she turned to 18 you know
bad baby right they catch me outside the
day she turned 18 she made it only fans
and then she showed her stats recently
and the first year she made 50 million
five zero five zero million what yeah
yeah yeah oh my god after only fans cut
it was like 43 but yeah it's ridiculous
good for her
yeah i was like dude that that's like
dynasty money
you put that in the
market and like you're you're great
great great grandkids won't have to
[ __ ] pay for [ __ ] one year on only
fans
wow
the certain point
just to make a point that's unrelated
does that make sense because he's like
women have certain privileges
yes
so why are you guys trying to impose
rules on men who don't have as many
privileges and it's like
who started comparing who said point
blank period women have more advantages
than men that's a fact
we just established that
women have more privileges would you
guys agree with that statement i'm
curious
in relationships women enjoy far more
privileges than men do they have all the
leverage when it comes to dating and
relationships
oh he he's saying because women are more
picky
than he is that they have more privilege
because
whatever the whole thing's so boring
you know what's interesting to me though
is that he we [ __ ] on these guys
mercilessly yeah and he never responded
to us this much but the minute pokeman
talks about him a little bit he does a
whole [ __ ] podcast about her
uh i find that interesting don't you
guys
yeah i mean from his perspective
it's probably smart i mean she
is
much much much bigger than them and so
she's talking about them and so on and
uh
right which is why well i mean they've
responded to us a bunch i didn't get my
own podcast
maybe not a whole one dedicated to it
that's true that's true
but yeah by play look at this right you
know you're right i mean it definitely i
mean he was obviously triggered like i
said i mean he went off on like a 10
minute ramp before she even opened her
mouth
does this guy say anything the whole
time no i mean other than it's
wednesday's
jokes
i'm afraid that you're gonna miss them
whenever he chimes in he's generally
just kind of saying the same thing the
other guy is saying but
stumbling over it the entire time and
not really articulating himself very
well so
i'm starting to feel bad for this guy
like is he like is he slow and i don't
mean that as an insult no i don't think
so i don't think so i feel bad for him
because i
knew he uh he immigrated here and i feel
like fit is one of the first people that
he met and he just kind of went along
with whatever he was saying he he
doesn't even belong there yeah he
doesn't even belong there i feel like he
don't hate women like the other guy do
you he just wants a homie yeah yeah so
he's fresh
he's got a big ass necklace so you're
gonna this is how i remember because
everyone always asks in the office i say
fresh coconuts
fresh coconuts
yeah fit is definitely the leader here
the guy hasn't said a word
i get the feeling he doesn't pay this
guy
he's just doing it for free yeah
i don't think he pays him violence for
them going against the grain this is why
so many girls are politically correct
this is why so many girls are not um
adversarial when it comes to viewpoints
in the way that they speak they go with
what mainstream media says because they
don't want to do women do they want you
to sit there and play by their rules
when they got their [ __ ] give it to them
meanwhile you had to bust your ass to
get it he's so angry do i even know why
you have no idea what he's talking about
i don't understand why he's so angry
like he's tall and he's like
like he has all the things that you
would like
that incellies would be like oh i wish
that like he's relatively attractive
he's tall like i'm why do you have so
much trouble with me with women because
your [ __ ] personality is horrible
dude
like you should be having a really easy
time with women
uh
with your natural blessings that you're
physically blessed with
i mean the hairline's struggling a
little bit but that's okay
not you know i saw it's fading in the
back but that's fine nothing to
criticize there but other than that he's
got it all
and i'm just saying
i think the reason women don't like you
is probably because you're just [ __ ]
horrible
all right let's do our stories that
turned out not that interesting
um
are you guys brought stats
let's move on
exactly yeah it's pretty boring
all right so here we have a topic that
we have a conversation topic
the dumbest thing you believed as a
child
now when i think about this i'm thinking
about like
when your parents be like if you come
out of bed it passed
past 9 00 p.m there's monsters in the
hallway that will like your parents tell
you some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that you believe for the rest of your
life
so everyone feel pretty good like they
got good ones
i think i got a pretty decent one
honestly i was struggling with this uh
i mean i had immediately thought of a
few but they just weren't
i don't know like
funny or that interesting just typical
kid [ __ ]
you know why don't you go yeah i feel
the same way i i made a list no you go
ahead and go first dan if you want okay
sure well the one that i was reminded of
this morning because i was talking with
the guys about
when i this is
when i was in elementary school
it must have been
it must have been like one of the first
days of kindergarten
i remember my dad was there with me to
drop me off at school
and
yeah it must have been one of the first
days because the principal was there
like greeting all the new kindergartners
that they came in and my dad leaned down
to me
and is like
okay well make sure behave yourself be
good
you see the principal right there do you
see his gun
his gun
you see it it's on his hip do you see it
oh my god he's like you better behave
yourself
oh my god
wow
and i
i thought he was totally serious and i
was like oh wow if you like if you're
if you like naughty at school like if
you get in trouble the principal's gonna
shoot you yeah
you believe that
i did when i was five did you keep in
line
for a time i definitely was a
troublemaker in school so i must have
realized it was [ __ ] at some point
there was some point where you realized
i can't believe that that's crazy it's
really kind of not strange
you didn't want to deal with your [ __ ]
that's a yeah that's my that's my dad
for sure though
he loves [ __ ] with people like that
i try my best with theodore because i
i think back on stuff like that
and i try my best to be like straight
with him about stuff
because i don't want him to one day be
like 18 years old and be like look back
right be like why did i think that uh
flushing too much toilet paper would uh
cause people in
a village in china to explode or use any
[ __ ] you know the toilet paper goes
through to china and people starved at
it i feel like parents back then maybe
didn't think about kids like that like
one day they're going to be adults and
look back at what they told us but
but like the way we are with theodore i
always
kind of
pretty much think about him as an adult
almost like i don't make up stuff stuff
like i don't tell him
don't do this because
the house will fall apart yeah
i don't know
i made a whole list here that one's
really good
this one's not someone so much uh
oh this one's a funny light one i'll
start with
i was probably 16 years old when i
discovered and don't judge me
i was in advanced english classes
you know i studied i was a good student
i found out that hole
like a hole in the ground and whole like
the whole thing
was different words
which just spelled different i thought
it was the same word
spelled the same the same word
and whole
and i was like
they're like no it's spelled they're
like hole
is spelled i was like the whole thing is
this then it's called the h-o-l-e
you're like no no i was like what
i don't know that's a hole it's a hole
it's a whole thing
it's a whole thing right you were picked
yeah like a hole in the ground
so the hole is everything in the hole
i felt pretty dumb about that
i had this weird thing when i was a kid
i would do this to myself i don't know
why i would torture myself i would go
okay
if i don't
go to the bathroom
and brush my teeth
fast enough
the boogie man there's a buggy man in
the closet and he's going to kill me in
my sleep
anyone ever do anything like that i feel
like yeah that's a common one i feel
like yeah you know what that reminds me
of see where did that come to you is it
from your parents i i don't know i don't
i don't blame them for that one there
was a there was an ad when i was really
young and it was a political ad and i'm
gonna describe this as i understand it
now
it was a political ad about how
um
you know
their opponent was uh throwing throwing
people to the wolves and the wolves are
at the door and in this political ad
they were showing like stock footage of
like wolves stalking through like a
snowy forest or whatever and i remember
seeing it on tv when i was a kid and i
didn't understand the context that this
was like a metaphor
and i fully believed that there were
just packs of wolves outside that could
just smash through my window at any time
and like just tear me out of bed and
carry me away
terrifying
i found it because i remembered that and
i found the commercial years later i'm
like yeah this was just like some
stupid-ass
politicians ad
that's the one i remember the most of
the boogeyman thing i'd be like
if i don't uh
do this if i don't uh clean up the my
put my clothes in the hamper real fast
it's usually when i'm going to bed
though and get in bed the but there's a
[ __ ] murderer under my bed who's
going to come out and chop my head off
when i'm sleeping i just really cruised
some weird [ __ ]
so i'm not alone on that eh yeah that's
good i kind of wonder if it started with
bloody mary weird i never really marry
never had that
what's bloody mary oh that [ __ ] me up
as a kid dude a movie no it's like uh
it's a game it's a stupid game oh well
you say bloody mary bloody into a mirror
oh yeah that shit's [ __ ] yeah you say
apparently they go
it's like a ghost spook story and you go
if you say
turn around three times and say bloody
mary
a ghost is gonna appear in the mirror
yeah you'll see bloody mary's reflection
in the mirror
i was there was one time i got [ __ ]
with so hard with that they locked me in
the bathroom
and turned the lights off and i was like
oh my god second grade it was horrible
that explains a lot yeah dude i [ __ ]
up what do you want from me
your joker brains that maybe is where it
all begins it's damaged
i'm damaged good but you got to take me
for what i am
and i do
and i love you i love you too
but that could have been the moment the
joker was born you're right yeah
um
this one
you know my mom has really nice skin and
i wish i learned more about hygiene at a
young age
because growing up whenever my skin was
you know you always have oily skin yeah
always at that age
and every time my skin felt oily i would
wash my face
right me too oh you did that i mean like
yeah i would bring soap with me to
school and wash my face
my face would just get so [ __ ] dry
and oily as a result and i just i would
wash you my face i'd go to a friend's
house and wash my face like [ __ ]
horrible
no i wish somebody told me just put on
moisturizer idiot just put it on your
face won't get oily
because it gets dry
i wish someone would have told me that
at a younger age
i don't know if our parents even knew
that stuff though
moisturize moisturize i don't know that
the new thing the oily skin like it's
kind of counter-intuitive but you
actually need to moisturize it it's
horrible just thinking back and i was
using like really hard face washes too
like really ones with like scrubbing
yeah bits in it and that also reminds me
i always thought that like to get really
good brush i brushed really hard right
and it gum the same thing and my gums
are [ __ ] up
i believe that uh
the any sex resulted in a baby
automatically
i may have told the story but once i
heard the one time i heard my parents
having
sex i don't remember what age i was
probably about five or six or seven i
don't know
but i just i heard some moaning
and i immediately excitedly got up and
went to my brother's
room it was like five in the morning
and i woke him up and i was like sean
there's great news i'm gonna i'm gonna
be an older brother
whoa and he was like what are you
talking about i was like mom and dad are
having sex
that's not how it works dude and i was
actually so disappointed oh i was so
happy i was like we're gonna have we're
gonna have another
i'm gonna be older brother
i'm not gonna be the baby anymore
[Music]
that i remember
and one more my brother used to [ __ ]
with me
he would used to tell me [ __ ] when i was
really young like
we have to wipe your ass you need to put
as much toilet paper as you can on your
hand
that's the proper way to wipe your ass
just to [ __ ] with me and get me in
trouble
and i started doing that like a whole
hand mitt and like a [ __ ] half a roll
of toilet paper
i was like that doesn't make much sense
i would clog in all the toilets and [ __ ]
[Music]
why did i do that just to [ __ ] just to
get me in trouble
that's it that's all i have nothing
really good
your sex one reminded me
last night when we said we were going to
do this as a discussion topic i was
racking my brain i couldn't i hadn't
thought of the principle thing yet
and so i asked ali my girlfriend um
or just told her i was like we're doing
this thing tomorrow i can't think of
anything and like immediately
immediately she came back with oh well
when i was like six years old i thought
the way the babies were made is that
like the mom and the dad they went to
the doctor's office and they would both
have a dixie cup and they would spit
into it and fill it up with spit and
then they'd exchange it and drink each
other's spit
i was like what where would i even learn
that that's what i asked and she's like
i have no nobody told me that like that
was just i just came to that conclusion
when i was like six years old that
that's where
i've never heard that no it's a new one
for me too that's gnarly
[Music]
um
you want to go so for me the first thing
that came to my mind as soon as you guys
said that was like
god
because
like it would be so stupid and sometimes
as an adult i think back about it and
i'm like wow it was kind of crazy like
you you kind of i would talk to myself
like
you're for example not supposed to eat
dairy after eating meat
and some people will wait six hours some
people wait three hours some people are
kind of like blurry about it and my
family was always kind of blurry about
like what you're
how much to wait
and so i would really want to eat like a
chocolate or something after dinner for
example
and so i would kind of be like okay i
waited 30 minutes
and then i'll eat it and i'll be like
okay god like just let this one go by
i'll be i won't do that ever again i
promise like that's it you felt really
guilty yeah and i've talked to god like
just
let this give me this one and but it
would happen on different occasions i
think that's very common for religious
kids i think they do that all the time
it's actually kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
up to kids so [ __ ] up
it's too much for kids to deal with this
idea of this god
always watching and hearing everything
and knowing everything a bit much
i think i think i think that's probably
very common for for kids religious
houses probably
but it seems like he forgave you if he
is there
you overlook that
i think he's not there
that's my conclusion
based on the fact that he never punished
you for the
chocolates
um
that's a good one
maybe you're nodding yes you had that
same kind of thing all right begging for
forgiveness please god what was the most
trivial thing you'd beg god for
forgiveness for i just always say god
please let my family go to hell when i
was a kid oh my god because i was mixed
and my aunts would always like tease me
about being half white and my mom being
american and i was really close with my
my grandma my mom's side so i'd say
please
don't let them go to hell come on
give me a break please god
why because you're half white
oh my god well just because they're not
muslim they're christian oh because your
mom's not muslim well my mom converted
but like my grandmother who was my
favorite person in the world was gushing
yeah oh you don't want her to go
fair enough
[Music]
who hasn't uh uh avery you want to do
yours yeah so
uh
one that i used to do is pretty
embarrassing is when i was a kid i was
trying to trace where it came from
i kind of think it may have been from
the movie hook which was like a 1993
film with rob williams yeah about peter
pan
i used to try to fly all the time i
would always just like
i'd wait until like the adults left the
room and i'd get up on something high
like the couch or the counter and try to
think of something like try to focus
hard enough or maybe think of a happy
thought and i try to fly that's right
yeah and i always fall and bust my ass
i remember my grandmother my grandmother
always saying something in arabic that
translates to like only time will tell
like i think only time will tell like if
he's if he's [ __ ] up or something like
every time i don't used to say that
about it yeah
and um
yeah i was telling lena it's crazy but i
was telling this story yesterday and
she's like oh maybe that's why you
always do that thing in college
at parties when you get really [ __ ] up
and throw yourself down the stairs and i
totally forgot about that for some
reason in college i thought this was the
funniest [ __ ] ever was to get messed up
and just throw myself from the top of
the stairs
down at a party and scare the [ __ ] out
of everyone downstairs and i do like a
little roll at the bottom and everyone
would crack up but i'd wake up always
the next morning being bruised on both
my uh
both my shoulders so yeah maybe that is
where it's from why because you want
your phone you thinking that you'll fly
i mean
no not that i thought i would fly when i
was older but just i was used to
throwing myself off of something so it
was just
interesting talented
talent entertainment
that's a shame that uh
as a kid you can't fly and do all this
cool stuff that looks awesome
it's [ __ ] up it's just not fair you
know what that reminds me of this
doesn't quite qualify because i don't i
don't think i ever fully believed this
but it was one of those things that like
as a kid you're like but maybe i should
try
do you remember the animorphs books when
we were kids yeah i love those covers i
thought that was so [ __ ] cool that
you could like absorb the dna of an
animal and then you could morph into one
and like at night like cat would jump
into my bed or something i'd be like all
right
let me see if i can do this
put my hand on my cat and like
concentrate really like i'm going to
absorb the dna so i can turn it into a
cat
never working yeah it's almost like uh
shifting you were doing i was trying to
shift i was trying to shift you were in
bed with your cat
sounds like a shift
like again i don't think i actually
believed it but i wanted it to be real
so bad that was like let's just give it
a shot let's just let's just jump right
into it let's just see where this leads
us
yeah it's crazy now that like my nieces
have no idea what anamorphs are i'm like
dude at the book fair those were like
you would never buy the books at least i
wouldn't have always just look at the
covers because they're always so
interesting covers are sick and
hilariously bad look at it
so stupid-looking
i mean here i'll show you some
yeah the art is actually just so bad now
when you look at it
i don't know if you've seen these either
look at this just don't know
[Music]
a snake
look at this one wow
yeah i read these in like second or
third grade so the concept is dope as
hell but like that art is [ __ ]
hilarious
and this was the cover of all of them
was just a kid it was one of the the
five teens that were like the
protagonists in it look at this a beaver
oh yeah you're going to transform into a
beaver of all the animals
i mean this kid turned into a fly that's
cooler than a beaver maybe were they
scholastic books
oh yeah right there yeah grizzly bears
is legit transformation
i can't say that
wait he transformed from a hawk to an
ant
to an alien
that was the kid that got trapped as a
hawk because the rules
the rule this is some deep animals lore
i'm about to drop on you but if you
state you could morph into any animal
that you absorb the dna of but if you
stayed in that form for too long i
forget it was like a couple hours or
something you get stuck and one of the
main characters gets stuck as a hawk
holy [ __ ] so his like base form is just
like a bird from now on those books were
like actually kind of [ __ ] twisted
you're the only person i know whoever
read them i never read one i never
really seen the one no i read them when
i was i used to read goosebumps that was
goosebumps was the [ __ ]
i had a whole collection of the
goosebumps i was seeing those at the
library like i remember the covers of
this so dope had the bumpy cover that
was like genius yeah oh yeah i always
just love the covers i don't think i've
ever read them what the [ __ ] is this
oh it's a lizard i thought oh god
what here's you dan this was you i know
it was trying i was trying
didn't work out for me
man there's just a lot of these
yeah they continue forever what
a starfish
why would you want to be a
starfish like a badass there was usually
some like you know plot motivation what
could a starfish do yeah that's a good
question i don't know why i just started
it sits there inertly basically yeah
trump turning into a halo
where'd it go
but there's some really funny ones like
i remember the agit
edget pie
anamorph meme oh yeah
remember that [ __ ] [ __ ] i remember
him i don't know what's the animal here
turning
[Laughter]
yeah there's some really good memes here
like uh somebody said animorphs
definitely made a lot of furries that's
interesting
oh okay
here's uh oh that's just that's rude
someone turns into the red
eminem sick
but yeah this is my favorite one yeah
this guy's such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
what a piece of [ __ ] he is
literally
yeah i don't get this one
trump turning into master chief
what no he's turning into a collab
oh i thought it was master chief's
helmet
see that that didn't make any sense to
me but what's the clam
i don't well the clam doesn't make more
sense yeah i don't know
[Laughter]
duck turning into a lizard
yeah so you get the idea
[Music]
feel like
what did you see
felix
turning into
duck
felix no
oh this oh yeah
i gotcha
so uh andy who's next who got one i'll
go all righty um
so this um this happened when i was in
like
fourth grade
brother comes in my room
he's four years younger than me
comes in my room and
he's carrying a
trojan condom
and a vibrating
penis dildo
a vibrating penis dildo
zack's brother is younger for context
younger and at the time i didn't know
what it was you know i don't i don't
know what how old were you i was in
fourth grade okay so you're both very
very young very young and he comes in my
room and he's like you know he's a
little zach what is this and i'm like i
don't know let's uh let's go ask mom and
dad oh [ __ ]
so
we go downstairs together
holding this pretty decent sized
vibrating dildo
and a condom
out of the wrapper in the wrapper in the
wrapper and i remember it was red and
that's a red interesting that's exotic
key point of the story right now
red condom is not common so we go
downstairs
and
my mom's jaw drops
and we're asking you know we
don't know what the [ __ ] this is and
we're asking like what is this my dad's
like well
the thing you're holding the red thing
is tylenol
okay interesting good good
he didn't say anything about the dildo
it was just
the red condom
so from
i don't know fourth grade till about
[ __ ]
seventh grade
i thought tylenol and condoms were the
same thing whoa
that's good so how did that impact your
life
not well
not i mean i but at that age you don't
you didn't know what was going on you
didn't know what it what a dildo was you
know or a condom yet but was there any
ever a time you asked for like a
uh explanation you got confused between
tylenol and condom
no because i you know
i figured out before i right started
using condoms you know
so
that's pretty good you ever talked to
your parents about it since then no
absolutely not
i'm gonna have to though after this
there you have it yeah
discovering that your parents have sex
is is traumatic
with a toy too i mean i told that story
with my mom when i found i found a dildo
next to her bed that's like
was the size of the [ __ ]
you did oh boy we did families i did it
right next to her
i swear to thing that thing was like
bro it was like the size of my arm
i swear to god and i you know that's a
lot to deal with
as a kid
i'm just saying
i was [ __ ] insane as an adult
yeah i remember that dildo i mean that
was [ __ ] massive dude
just totally out of
the problem and the thing is they didn't
even hide it that well that's what they
could have protected me yeah that's how
i feel too like come on man
i don't need to live with that memory
i remember the dildo so vividly in the
condom it's so vivid it's just trapped
in my mind
yeah
[Music]
but at least it seemed like it was like
human size not like horse size
[Music]
it was one of those dildos that had the
clitoral stimulation on it too
so okay so you learned so you
in retrospect you're learning a lot
about what you saw practice
oh [ __ ]
there you have it condoms are tylenol
ladies and gentlemen there you go
ian you got it you gotta have something
good for us
uh
i mean i was a smart kid
i didn't believe anything stupid
no that's not true um
there was this girl in my first grade
class i just sit next to her name was
mckenna and she was always messing with
me
that bloody mary thing she
she told me about that and she would
actually like take a paper clip and she
would scratch up her arms oh my god and
i didn't realize that was what was
happening until later but she would be
like i did the bloody mary thing again
last night and i was so scared nasty
what yeah she would have like cuts all
over her arms
um it's dedication yeah
you know method the jared leto type yeah
acting
um but
one thing she told me
that
is so stupid i was such an idiot she
told me that um
if you ever go to legoland
when you the moment you set foot in the
park you turn into like a big lego man
and i was like
whoa that's so sick how do they even do
that and she's like they have like the
most advanced technology it's crazy like
disneyland can't catch up it's so good
and i was like begging my parents to go
to legoland i wanted to go so bad
and they took me eventually
and i i was like right at the entrance i
was like
here we go and i stepped in and i was
like
this place [ __ ] sucks i was so upset
and i was like i was grumpy the whole
day i was so disappointed she really got
here yeah
the park
there's like nothing there it's well how
old were you when you went how old
uh probably like second grade ish oh way
too old yeah
because we take theodore and
since he's like two
he loves it yeah theodore loves it but i
feel like five max for that
i didn't even are there you went
recently right there yeah they're like
rides and stuff or i don't remember
doing rides just stuff to look at the
rides are pretty bad for like three
years yeah it's not
like a little train ride a little boat
ride it's all really really really
low-end [ __ ]
and you're a human the whole time no you
don't transform there's no metamorphosis
so did you hit her up when you came back
yeah i was like
i was like what the hell like i went to
legoland nothing nothing happened
and she was like oh they must have
changed it
oh
wow
that's [ __ ] you guys that's a
snicker
and right here
she's a sneaky little trickster yeah
yeah
messing with you she got me good she
could tell i was a rube so easy mark
oh sam you got one
i was waiting for a permission from my
mom
but she's not texting me back really you
need permission for this one yeah but
i'm just gonna tell it anyway yay
so
one day i was in my parents bathroom and
i don't remember what i was looking for
but i opened a drawer and i found some
lube and i asked my mom i was like
what is this and she was like it's
lotion
and i was like oh okay cool
so
for months after that i would go into
their bathroom and use their bathroom
and wash my hands and i would like put a
dab of
lotion
on my hands and i would just i was
always like oh this lotion sucks
and then i think i told my mom about it
one day like this lotion doesn't smell
very good and she was like what are you
talking about and i showed her and she
was like oh
oh no she was like that's that's our
lotion don't don't use our lotion
oh my god that's funny
that's very funny
kids are so funny how they remember
stuff like that like theodore would
totally
do that
you tell him one thing he's coming back
to use it that way
for sure
that's hilarious that's awesome
nasty too
because you know her hands were like had
like sex [ __ ] on it when she touched
the battle
i'm just saying you know just saying
you didn't think i thought about that
retrospect when i picked up my mom's
massive [ __ ] dildo stop terrific i
know insane same for me mama too yeah
it's part of the trauma
[Music]
i can't wash off my hands now still
been washing my hands
ever since that touched that thing man
um cam
lina
yeah i i got one can i come over there
talk just as easier to chat over there
we would love to see you
come on cam camily family family family
family
hello everybody
can you hear me all right cool uh so
similar to ian i had a
a girl that used to mess with me like in
elementary school
and this is a story that i believed up
until maybe one or two months ago
oh wow yeah i mean because it's so
grounded in potentially reality i guess
and i
wouldn't have any other way of knowing
but uh
sh this girl in like first second third
grade whatever
told me that all girls bathrooms had uh
couches in them
oh interesting i've heard that before
you have okay i wasn't sure yeah so is
this grounded in reality and like no
hell no okay because i was talking to i
was talking to a girl like a couple
months ago and i told her that and she
thought she told me it was put on and
all these years i thought i had
something similar where they they
convinced me that there's like sofas and
vases and flowers well so here's the
thing
i brought this up this morning and a b
made me reconsider if it was even fake
because he said
in an episode of the office they go into
the
all the guys hang out in the girls
bathroom and it's a similar setup to
what you just described so i'm starting
to wonder is like what have i been
double lied to is there couches in the
girls bathrooms now i don't know i think
it's a meme i think it's an ongoing game
okay yeah well that can't be but the the
truth is that the women's bathroom is
more [ __ ] than the guy's bathroom it's
horrific in there man in my mind i was
like oh they don't have urinals so
exactly it's nice
you know they need a spot to hang out
and there's less space in there so i
don't know but you know i'm still not
convinced that's how they trick you
because you go oh women are nice they're
respectful they're considerate their
bathroom's not gonna be a dump no you go
in there and it's [ __ ] up i've never
been in one so i you know i'm still i'm
on the edge you gotta go in
i'm there a lot of
people in the chat say that some do yeah
see what hell no stop it you guys real
don't [ __ ] with poor cam it's not real
come on all right wait ela's saying it's
not real lena sam
what what's going on here
there's no couches in women's bathroom
without you i've noticed if you go to
like the mall they always say like
women's lounge or whatever and there are
like couches it's like a little seating
area really yeah like at nordstrom yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay what well so there's a little bit
of truth to it
what is that yeah what do you need a
couch for yeah
hanging out
what's up when you're hanging out in the
bed you bought
sam said like if you just at the mall or
something there's usually a couch in the
bathrooms there but it's not like every
bathroom i've never even heard of that
before well well if if there's a couch
at
so can we really
yeah i wouldn't count that as like wait
what cam is talking people want to pull
well it was my perspective that like
every woman's everyone knows is bomb in
the elementary school and like yeah
all that you know stores everywhere no
way
people say it's breastfeeding yeah i see
that
breastfeeding
that would be nice yeah that's that's
nice
but yeah i think there still might be
couches in the bathrooms i think it just
might be a secret society yeah
everybody's saying maternity
breastfeeding okay that makes sense okay
yeah
what but we're talking about like nice
places right not like every yeah
it's not common
i mean i've accidentally walked into a
women's bathroom and then i go and i see
all stalls and no urinals and then i
panic and i go oh [ __ ]
i'm in the wrong place
[Music]
all right
but you guys can't sit you guys can't
say oh yeah yeah i'm actually a genius
after all thank you very much
you guys can't say every bathroom has a
couch stop that
stop the madness i worked in a nordstrom
and there are couches and flowers in
there oh my god okay but you're talking
about north strong yeah
people are saying it's pretty common
what
there you go
so that you you know fresh and fit we're
onto something [ __ ] male female
privilege i don't see it where do you
see it i see people saying only if it's
like a nice place fancy place
not a not a public elementary school
probably not all right do a poll does
every bathroom
does every woman's bathroom have a couch
a vase
and fly fresh flowers
every single one
i mean obviously obviously not
watch let's see
the women i'm telling you
secret society it is
that's what the chamber of secrets
actually is
100 yes right now
so cam okay eighty percent now
twenty percent say yes all men and it's
back one in five women admit there are
in fact so i think you've got bamboozled
yeah slightly bamboozled you know i i i
will never know i guess but
you may know
you will know one day i'm so confused my
whole life has been a lie and then just
this morning it got you know flipped
back around so i'm not sure right but
wait you've never accidentally walked
into the women's bathroom um okay so
when i worked at adult swim uh me and
we would work late nights a lot and so
it was just you know the empty the
building's very empty at that time and
me and
my friend christina she was like hey you
want to see the girls bathroom i just
like you know because it was different
there
and i was like sure and i remember
noting like there's no there's no
couches in here
interesting that's awesome
this was odd but it wasn't but it was a
better bathroom than the men's bathroom
too so i did know that as well that's
funny
where are the couches
[Music]
all right nice 50 dollars i think my
university had one in their i.t building
that's not
that's not very fancy i mean unless they
were had what in the it building
a couch in the women's bathroom
at a university
it's not just normal it can't be in the
back the bathroom is gross it's going to
be out of the bathroom and like a lounge
area no
yeah
because the bathroom there's water oh
there's [ __ ] not in the back
definitely not that's gross
upholstered couch
soaking up all those odors
hi elena hi you got a good one um i
think so
so
i guess it's sort of an arab
superstition but when i was younger i
was told that whenever a bride when
you're at a wedding and you first see
the bride enter for the first time you
have to say smaller or sha allah which
is like a way to keep the evil eye away
otherwise it's going to bring like
really bad luck to her and the story was
that
the mother of a bride at some wedding
she was so concerned with telling
everyone um to say smalla that she
forgot to do it herself and so
um the next day the bride went blind
oh my god
that's this is like a story or this
happened a tall tale okay yeah okay so
the mom the mom was so concerned with
everyone saying it that she forgot yeah
okay yeah wow i was young when this
happened so when i
and i think i was like early middle
school when my sister was getting
married and when she was first coming in
for the first time i was like looking
around and like making sure everyone's
going to say i just had really bad
anxiety about it that something was
going to happen to me
someone would forget oh
there
my
god
many ridiculous ones do you have any
other ones about
i mean
i was told once that if you have shrimp
and orange juice you're going to die if
you eat them at the same time oh my god
wait lina were you like going up to
people and making sure they said it or
were you just sitting there super
stressed out yeah i was too shy to do
that but um just yeah just super
stressed out like looking around and it
made me really nervous for her
and and the next day were you waiting
for her to go blind or something or did
you forget about it already i forgot
about it or maybe i talked to my mom
about it and she told me that wasn't
true or something like that
serious business yeah
but she's okay your sister she's okay no
blindness yeah you don't know she's all
right enchilada right are we
she wise
yeah i'm dylan
yeah but for arab kids in general like i
feel like we all have this sort of like
anxiety that something bad is going to
happen like we were at a lake one day
and my niece who was six at the time
just randomly said
looking around she's like i never came
here today yeah she's like i have a bad
feeling about today he just may not have
come here today what the heck i'm
talking about and she's like i don't
know i just have a very bad feeling
oh
and that's
it's because arabic is such a dramatic
language that when it's translated it
comes out so bad so like
lena always told me the story of when
her mom walked downstairs once when they
were watching a scary movie they were up
late and what'd she tell you
oh yeah just because we are staying up
late and it's not good you know we need
sleep but yeah she's like
like
hopefully you guys get sick and die
yeah
wait
wait
you were up too late and she said i hope
you get sick and die yeah like that's
what you get for not sleeping oh she's
good you guys stay up but she's hoping
for it
and then in translation that's what it
is yeah but it's like worse
does it does it means kind of like if
you guys get sick and die it's the
result of you staying sort of yeah it
doesn't translate very well that's so
funny like baby said arabic is just a
very dramatic language i hope you get
sick and die
it's funny because now that they're all
adult turner siblings they all like
start to think about these different
phrases they heard growing up like holy
[ __ ] have you ever thought about what
the translation means like their mom
will always say i'm gonna i'm gonna hit
you so hard you're gonna fly across the
room and hit the hit the wall or
something yeah it's always dramatic
oh my god i'm damn that's brutal that's
dramatic do you feel like that was like
did you take you didn't take it
seriously when she said that or was it
were you kind of shocked or is it normal
no normal yeah like amy said we didn't
really think of the translation that was
just like her saying stop doing that
yeah
whoa
there you go
that's pretty grim
[Laughter]
and did you ever figure out why your
niece was feeling so so uh do me that
day no i mean we're asking her maybe
something happened or
but no
she just had a bad feeling i guess
got a bad feeling about today guys
what's the difference from inshallah
inshallah means uh god willing yeah
alhamdulillah means like thank god
garbage
am i saying all right
oh hamdillah yeah you're adding like
four extra songs yeah i don't know
because i'm used
this is what evil's dad used to do when
you
you go ham dela
no you wouldn't say it oh you mean like
no not but this is the movement
um
it kind of goes for like a lot of stuff
it's like it's like a what can you do
kind of thing
there you go
good
anyone else
we have love
a love what do you got for us
uh i guess my story is a little bit mid
maybe not that good as sax for example
but
as a kid i used to have this like really
when i'm reflecting back at it really
obsessive like ocd thoughts
um maybe a little bit like you ethan
that you felt like you had to do
something like clean your face
uh
and i had to like every time i went to
the bathroom i had to tap this specific
spot on the wall
uh
that that's basically just an
introduction but
i thought
in every pool of water no matter how
small that there would be a shark that
would eat me
and it could be like a kid or not a kid
pool but like any water where i could
not touch the button i guess
and
i always had this in my mind and uh
so i randomly sometimes if i felt
something on my foot i had to get out of
the water because i thought it was a
was a
shark and
well one day when i kind of grew up uh
my dad told me he knew i was scared of
sharks uh
so he told me there's no sharks in like
swedish waters and i said oh okay
and i asked is there anything else
is there nothing that can like hurt me
and he said
oh there's this one fish but
that exists in swedish waters and from
like then on i was just scared of this
fish instead
i don't remember what it's called in
english but
it's basically just a tiny like meat
eating fish super tiny little berry
no it's called
in sweden swedish i don't know but it's
basically like this long fish that eats
other fish i was like scared
so badly of
anything like that i had that paranoia
too about sharks and swimming pools it's
like so stupid and weird
but i used to also be scared of sharks
and swimming pools i actually found a
picture of the fish that i think he's
talking about
[Music]
oh those are scary dangerous
yeah
that's it but yeah reflecting back at
some of the things i did when i was a
kid i probably had like bad ocd i don't
want to like diagnose myself or anything
like that yeah
like horrible ocd like tapping the wall
before going to the bathroom tapping the
roof before i go out of my
bedroom i still have some of those
tendencies
but way less you know what love i had
the shark thing too
oh yeah i was the same way no matter
where i would think sharks were coming
towards me
yep i think we do those things to
comfort ourselves uh being a kid is
stressful
yeah yeah
but you know that reminds me did you
guys ever hear the story of when you're
in the pool of some kid they got stuck
to the pool drain and drowned yeah
that doesn't happen does it yeah it does
no that's real
what scared the [ __ ] out of me the pump
it's like incredibly strong
really but how do you get stuck to the
point usually like like a little
particle of your clothing gets sucked
into it
or like if if uh you have long hair your
hair gets sucked into it or something i
believe more modern pools if there's
multiple of those uh
pumps like if there's more than one of
them it'll like automatically balance it
so that that can't happen but no that
was that is a real thing that you know
kids have drowned because they get stuck
at the bottom of the pool i'm reading up
i'm gonna see how many
how many times this actually happened
hair caught in the drain
you can get disemboweled if it sucks
your [ __ ] out of your ass what
what
it says there are many hazards
associated with swimming pool drains
the swimming pool pump suction
has risks including hair getting caught
in the drain yeah and then quote suction
and disembowelment
i saw on the news once when i was a kid
a guy stuck his thing inside a jacuzzi
drain
and he got stuck there yeah that i
believe yeah that i have no trouble
believing
disembowelment though it can suck your
hands out
you fear unlocked
well just don't put your ass over the
[ __ ] pool drain
about
shoes
that's what a disembowelment means
specifically it means your intestines
come out of your butthole
[Music]
okay
but over here growing up that peeing in
a pool will change the color of the pool
yeah yeah that's a good one yeah they go
we have a special chemical in the pool
so if you pee it's going to turn bright
red and we'll all know
be real have you ever been in a pool and
not peed yes because i still believe
that chemical thing wait
have you ever been ever been in a
position
yeah every time you go on the block yeah
you guys heard that right yeah
like be real here dog i mean yeah i'm
being very real like no definitely not
but do you pee in the pool every time
you go in a pool
kelly what like every like 100 of the
time you pee in it like you hold it to
go pee in the pool no no no i'm just
saying like if you're in the pool and
you got a piss you're not gonna get out
and like go no you do
yeah i started doing that i gotta be
honest yeah at my own home especially in
the hot tub there's not a lot of water
in there i might get out and go pee
right but also like
out like at this day if we're out in a
pool i will get out to pee yeah i would
too but
i don't know but there's been times all
people
yeah that was a
long period of time that i probably did
zach kind of just uh
we weren't all there with you that time
this time zach fair enough i mean you
expect kids or oh hey chantel you hear
that
zac p's in every pool he goes in
yeah me too
she said she believes it
that's my man she said proud of you
i have a feeling you do too by the sound
of it
but i mean zack
like it depends are you at like a
family's home in their pool i mean
you don't want to pee in someone's pool
that has like kids and [ __ ]
no
but
that wasn't very forceful
all i'm saying is i just don't see any
logic of getting out of the pool
well all of that here
there's so much chlorine in the [ __ ]
pool it's going to kill technically i
know it's not bad but also
i don't want to know that my kids are
swimming in my piss
but i feel like the chlorine kills it
okay piss is sterile so you it doesn't
matter you can swim in a pool of pure
bits and be fine chlorine's gonna kill
the yellow whatever
it's how i'm rationalizing in my brain
wait until you have kids and you see
them drink the water yeah
fair point
interesting
what do you guys want to pull for i mean
look people pee in pools i know that
but you pee every time you swim not
every time you're gonna tell me there's
not a single person in here that
doesn't pee in the pool
no no no i have everybody's peed in a
pool i don't think
i haven't you've never peed in a pool no
dan's why would you do that oh i've
eaten
many times yeah many many many many
times
you've never peed in a [ __ ] pool dan
no what's wrong with you
i feel like i'm in the upside-down world
right now i peed in the talking about
many many many times in my life dan
thought the lifeguard was going to shoot
him right now
now we do need a pole okay so paul have
you ever peed in a pool just once
because apparently that's crazy to dance
so now that i'm interested
have you ever peed in a pool once yes or
no it's got to be like 90 yes
i can't recall peeing in a pool really
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] people are
saying i'm lying what is wrong with you
people what's wrong with you okay well
hold on let's see because i don't piss
like in things so you're swimming around
it i don't want to swim around in my own
piss dan you're going to be horrified
but 76 percent yes
[Applause]
never go did you not know that everyone
does that
you didn't know that everyone pees in
the pool i know that people do do that
but like if you're going out everybody
have you ever peed in the pool once
99 of the time is gonna be yeah
well 77 well we have two people who have
never done that with shocks i've never
done it i'm really recalling it i'm sure
maybe when i was a kid obviously oh i
pee in the i've been in the pool many
times i'm i'm with dan too
wait the [ __ ]
i don't know 77 said yes that's all i'm
saying you're nasty but this poll says
have you ever
i'm curious to see if
ever
regularly yeah not regularly i'm just
i'm just saying i'm curious how many
regularly pee in a pool oh
well i don't know
well i haven't i haven't been swimming i
don't care about it regularly
that's weird i know these are like
weirdos that's like making a point like
when i go in the pool i pee in it i'm
not saying every time i go in a pool
like this i'm just that's what you said
that's literally what it is no no no no
no no no you're just saying that i think
he meant it as a
you didn't mean it literally the first
time you said it right right he
literally said no no no i will i don't
think maybe all right fair enough i
won't make it a point
but you know i just i think it's you
regularly pee in pools 75 no 25 says yes
though a quarter people just every time
they're in the pool they just let it rip
i'm surprised that surprised you
i'm surprised that surprised you i'm
very surprised we're learning things
today 75 of people have peed in pools my
friends it was actually going up it was
at 77 when you ended it it's just
therapy right now have you been in pools
a lot then and everybody that said no
yeah i mean one yeah okay at one point
when i was growing up uh uh i our house
had a pool i swam all the time yeah
everyone was peeing in there
practicing swimming too and i never
think it
you know what that was the house that
andy dick came and crashed the party
yeah
yeah he for sure
yeah he probably wasn't even in the pool
you want yeah
you know i'm gonna ask him you responded
to me you want me to ask the gp in dance
you pool i was at a public did you
message him zach yeah i'm not no i'm
having back and forth with him
no you're not no he responded andy dick
yeah he why didn't you update me i i
mean i didn't he didn't want him to call
in today well i want to know what are
you guys talking about oh okay
so i'm like hey i said andy i work for
the h3 podcast we want you to call on
the show he said how what number do i
call then he gave me his phone number
same number you have
different one okay that's my number just
call me when you're ready i'm just
sitting here then he called me two times
via instagram facetime
i said not today got a new jimmy lee
exactly i said not today are you
available sometime next week what do you
want to talk about
whatever's happening
this day to me
which is always a lot did he talk [ __ ]
about me
no that's the big question yeah ask him
about that being very civil
so no ask him
okay yeah did was he talking smack about
me that's what sparked the whole thing
yeah yeah
yeah can't believe you've been chatting
them up the whole damn time it's only
been a few back and forth we need to
start wrapping up the show but yeah i
was about to say we are well we touched
on something really good here is that
i'm surprised i cannot believe y'all
i can't believe you all but you're in
the minority
of our audience
what do you mean our audience i don't
know apparently there's a certain type
excuse us well
yeah
you're [ __ ] weird man no i love our
audience they're right you're wrong
one time i was swimming in a public pool
and there was just i was me and my
cousins were trying to go see if we
could go lower and i went really close
to the ground and there's a big piece of
[ __ ] there
that i've never done i've never heard
no no no no no okay that's like i've
never shipped
never done it i've never seen it
you know what's really [ __ ] when i was
in pola uh water polo
uh in high school we had to wake up at
like four am five am ungodly hours for
practice
and i don't know who was doing this but
somebody who was like i don't want to do
practice tomorrow they would take a [ __ ]
and throw it in the pool come on
every time there was a [ __ ] in the pool
they had to clean out the water and
that's a practice
so it happened like many times
throughout the year where someone would
[ __ ] in the pool
and then it was always like yo there's
[ __ ] in the pool again can't prick
practice is canceled but somebody was
[ __ ] in the pool regularly oh man at
my school
that's [ __ ] funny it's kind of genius
too yeah i mean we were all stoked we
were like yeah
somebody [ __ ] in the pool again [ __ ]
awesomes best day so great
so shout out whoever's doing that
you know who you are
was it bleeding the [ __ ] was it like
breeding brown or was it kind of solid
it's so weird how perfectly i could
still see it yeah tell me about it no it
would look it looked like it had algae
on it or whatever it's been there a
minute yeah that's like you've been
there a minute
i remember i came out and uh
i wasn't that dangerous or something
i can't remember my mom right
and then like right after i like i felt
like i was you know a good citizen i was
like i looked around like everyone here
probably thinks i [ __ ] just [ __ ] in
the pool
because i just
i bet some people do think that
the world was convinced my cousin did it
yeah i don't know the worst is like
getting out of the pool when you have to
[ __ ] because you get on the toilet it's
a [ __ ] slip and slide yeah oh yeah
yeah for sure
pretty cool matter i've never [ __ ] in
the pool i can tell you that's kind of
kind of like a gross concept to people
taking shits and then going back into
the pool well you've seen those signs
that say if you've had diarrhea in the
last 24 hours don't go swimming yeah
no one goes back when they're there and
they've had it
they're like see that sign i'm like yeah
no one's gonna know hell no
let me find one of those diarrhea
swimming warning
fecal matter i pooped my pants
that's crowder eh
no al roker
oh i keep thinking that
yeah
here it is
notice persons
yeah
persons having currently active diarrhea
or who have had active diarrhea within
the previous 14 days
14 days 14 pages
should not be allowed to enter the pool
water it's 14 pages this is this is
diarrhea's hate this is this is we need
to
advocate for diarrhea people rights 14
days meticulously argued document 14
days of meticulous diarrhea it's because
the germs they could leave in the water
it could
make over 100 million germs it's saying
uh
and you only need 10 of those to get
sick
14 days
you tell me i stopped at your ring two
weeks ago and i can't swim
what the [ __ ] does that mean human fecal
matter
that's outrageous
[Music]
14 days on the regularly poll it's at 30
yes
pretty wild that's pretty high
all right now let's just do one more for
the road and guys be honest have you
ever [ __ ] in a pool
just be honest with us
so when are we doing a uh h3 pool party
at your house
well mostly all our responsible kings
do you guys still want to go in our pool
if zach has like
no i don't pee in our pool
the one that really grossed me out
though is the hot tub because there's
just not enough water in there to dilute
the pea
like pablo cotton any hot dub
because you think
i've thought well if i'm in the pool i'd
pee but in the hot tub that seems really
[ __ ] gross oh
i'd agree with you on that one it's just
not enough water to make it okay
plus you got the bubbles
[Laughter]
just not enough water uh have you ever
[ __ ] in a pool uh
94 no
i'm gonna assume the six percent are
probably just trolling six percent
that's really high
well shout out to all y'all out there
they'd be [ __ ] in pools
that's [ __ ] great
yo 14 days from having diarrhea
you can recover from kidney from getting
your kidney removed faster than that
on page 14.
somebody just donate 20 bucks instead
all the time you spend 20 bucks to uh
say you [ __ ] in the pool
my kind of person right there all right
shout out ashley who shits in the shout
out ashley constanellos who [ __ ]
oh man that's funny pee in the shower oh
every time always pee in the shower
every time i've peed in the shower 100
of the time i aim for the drain though
so i'm not just like in it that's the
thing with the pool that's the
difference is like you you're
swimming in the water that you're
actively peeing i don't even look where
i pee i want to pee in a tub i agree
with you you're taking a a bath you
wouldn't pee no i wouldn't pee in the
bath well not
it's not enough water
okay ethan let me ask you when you take
a [ __ ] and you're planning on taking a
shower after do you wipe then shower yes
are you okay yeah definitely i always
wipe
because i don't want to be dealing with
chunks of [ __ ] on my ass with my hand i
feel you i feel you but i don't get the
feeling you don't do that no i do you do
okay yeah definitely wipe
always wipe i stopped peeing in the
shower once i got married that was one
of the signs that like i really love
lena because just because i respect that
she's like such a clean freak
oh she's a real friend i feel really bad
about it so wait what you say what would
you say i peed in the shower before i
was married but now that i'm married to
lena we live together i don't you hear
that lena
would you be mad if if he peed in the
shower
no i do that
there you go
i'm sorry but he didn't tell me that
once and i said that was very thoughtful
oh
sheep he's in the shower wait till we
get home girl i'm about to be like the
quartering i'm just going to piss
everywhere
i just peed in my basement i'm about to
pee in my shower
so would you say you pee every time lena
no i was just joking about that but um
oh you don't be in the shower no yeah i
don't
but he has permission to pee in the
shower
yeah i guess i wouldn't mind it
a little hesitant yeah just with the eye
gas you're doing the right thing
yeah it sounds like she appreciates the
talking but i know ela doesn't pee we go
in there we shower together we both pee
freely
oh you said doesn't pee no you pee yeah
you don't care
i don't care i mean if you were like
please don't pee in the shower i
wouldn't but i would probably push back
a little bit where i was like
it's the shower but you don't care
i'm i'm curious would you guys be in the
shower if you guys lived with your
parents or is it just because you live
with a i would be in the shower in any
condition bro oh yeah my ex is the same
thing yeah i won't and then i just piss
in the shower and give a [ __ ]
i don't care who's showering after me
i'll be in that [ __ ] it's like a habit
at this point it's like part of taking a
shower for me it's not the grossest
thing being washed off your body let's
be honest
you know
i just donated two dollars and said my
cousin's [ __ ] on a slip and slide
that just really got me
oh my god
that's wrong
this is wrong wait we got to do a pull
peeing in the shower because that's got
to be like 100 right do all you guys be
in the shower
yeah
yeah
well yeah that's why we said yes i
looked at you and not i'm having i'm
getting the feeling man love is uh
outlier here yeah wait you don't be in
the shower so that's why i asked about
your if you live with your parents i
kind of feel like i would if i had my
own apartment but i tend to
i don't know i kind of feel like it's
weird
i guess that means you don't jerk off in
the shower
no that's jerking off in the shower when
you share it with someone that's a lot
peeing i don't see the issue 83 say yes
i just have a habit of going before i go
into the shower
yeah that makes sense
but that is specifically because i live
with my dad you share a bathroom with
your dad
yeah
we don't have two bathrooms yeah
yeah i told a story about a roommate who
jerked off in the shower and got it
clogged every time i need to look at his
[ __ ] nasty splooge every time i got
awful that was traumatic dude that was
so bad bro
and i had to literally get out and be
like dude listen
i don't want to ever have to have this
conversation because it makes me
uncomfortable i'm sure it makes you
uncomfortable
but you've got to stop jerking off in
the shower i can't deal with this
anymore somebody said it stinks up the
shower like pee after and no it doesn't
what the hell what do you do where are
you
you pee and then the water rinse where
are you peeing the water see where the
water goes from showering it's like
seriously come
if it smells like pee
stop and also where are you peeing
that's funny that said your roommate
would do it in the shower i had a
roommate that would steal my [ __ ]
socks no i swear to god and i would jizz
in your socks and then he would just
like toss him and i every like
organized person ever did he not own his
own socks no he didn't
are you sure he didn't have a thing for
you no that's like jerking in your
underwear he was on drugs he was on some
hardcore drugs
our spoons were missing that was
basically like stealing your panties bro
yeah i know i was very [ __ ] agitated
i'd be on my way to work and i was a
waiter and i could not find matching
socks how'd you know he's taking your
socks because i
i found one in his room and it was a
very distinct stock i saw him work
because i had a red bottom because i got
him somewhere else anyways he
i was like i knew you would steal my
[ __ ] socks and i was going to go grab
me he goes you don't want to touch that
it's nasty no no no no no so did you you
suspected he was taking your socks yeah
i thought he was just taking cause he
wanted to wear him yeah just to wear him
yeah because he took all my clothes and
he would always deny it but okay
but he was jerking off into him yeah
[ __ ] that's
crazy dude
how did you react to that
believe it or not him [ __ ] in my
socks was like the least of our worries
he's a rough time was he taking other
people's socks too no it's just me and
him and his girlfriend
did a girlfriend there
she know me about his ceiling [ __ ]
initially it was worse than him what in
god's name
[Music]
damn
somebody just asked do the crew have
shower beers or just an aussie thing
is that
what is that sour beer
i mean i've had a beer in the shower
once i think just like for a laugh
hold on hannah call definitely not a
regular thing
anna called donated five bucks you said
i poop in the shower and waffle stomp it
down the drain
no you don't i think that's a gag it's
gotta be a joke
i don't know if i told a story about
when i convinced one of my roommates
that i [ __ ] in the
in the tub and waffle stomp it
i planned it super detailed ahead of
time because we used to [ __ ] with each
other and try to convince each other the
most ridiculous thing
so i i casually brought her up i was
like yeah i [ __ ] in the shower and stomp
it down and he's like a clean freak he's
ocd it was isaac
he's like please tell me you don't do
that he started melting down he's like
you're [ __ ] with me i said call call
my friend call my buddy kareem and we
have planned this all out ahead of time
with two other friends
and he goes kareem do you [ __ ] in the
shower he goes yeah everyone sits in the
shower
and i was like bro what are you talking
about
as i call jay uh call james
ah
james like yeah i shouldn't have [ __ ] in
the shower sometimes and he was like
please god please tell me you're kidding
i can't [ __ ] it
having like existential crisis
he's good and he's a clean freak yeah
he's a total clean free
and obviously we were sharing a shower
so he said at one time i was forced to
poop in the shower and i had to
transplant it into the toilet dude what
situation were you forced
my dumbass cousin puked in the shower
when the the damn toilet was right there
the [ __ ] guy left there for like five
days oh
huge ass said i have to shower with the
toilet seat down it freaks me out to
look at the water in the toilet
i have a weird phobia about it
okay
oh university of oregon recently put out
a notice asking students not to pleasure
themselves in the showers
i got a feeling that probably happens a
lot the thing that people don't
understand is that
when semen gets wet it turns it's really
like
it can clog very strange like yeah
consistency it gets like um
newtonian fluidy
right just it gets sticky and it doesn't
um mix with the water yeah
that's weird it tastes good it does
taste good though it's like a milk a
different type of melon
yeah semen is
it's disgusting it's revolting all right
you all have to be on the road at 4 30.
okay but hopkins gave 10 bucks they said
i'm taking a risk sending this because
i'm broke
but i have a video that i think will
make video a lot it's poop related and
i'd love to try to make ethan laugh um
i don't know if we have time for a video
send it to
i don't know i don't know uh just try to
if you can get dan then send him the
video
yeah just dms all right guys time for
some tgif fridays
wait let's plug before we go what are
the cards yeah the cards the end
the pre-sale ends tonight
so this is your last chance
to get the h3 cards did we get a sales
update cam
this is it's ending tonight at midnight
at midnight east coast time so actually
if you're on the west coast
uh 9 p.m and if you're in hawaii or
alaska i don't remember what the time
difference is but a few hours prior to
that so here you go guys is your last
chance to get the h3
trading cards all profits
are going directly to the crew
am not taking any of it
and this will never be sold again no
limited edition yeah
they're very shiny collectibles here so
get your hands on these before before
they're gone
look at that pristine
you're really cool there you go 25 bucks
um there you have it uh rap trading dot
co yeah and the link is in the
description thank you don't open the
package you can slide this out on the
ebay
six and a half thousand sales cam oh wow
that's so cool that's nuts that's gonna
be like a real some serious money there
for you guys
shut up
wait that's great well we're good we're
splitting it with him so i guess it's
not as much whoa dude that's a lot of
money
nice
yeah mr rap trading he's uh
well he deserves it i mean these are
amazing he did like they're they're so
legit if you've ever like played magic
or pokemon cards or whatever it it's
like a real trading card yeah the
yeah this is perfect the foil the you
know reflectiveness you guys are just
gonna get like 10 000 bucks i think
yeah you spoke too soon when you said we
could keep it also thank you no i don't
care i'm happy i don't want it yeah well
thank you yeah
appreciate it that was very kind of you
guys actually get that rolling that's
sick zach i know you're almost there
it's gonna be there
you
[Music]
so thank you thank you everyone yeah
that's right again because really he
worked on this for like seven months we
were going back and forth with him he's
a g man yeah do you do you want to know
exactly how much we're getting each or
you have the number
yeah i calculated it real quick yeah
tell me i'm sure
this is after his cut
after he's caught yes okay so plus or
minus a couple hundred bucks 6.6 k oh
well how many people is that split
between
uh nine or oh it's more than a little
bit more than yeah nine congrats guys
that's awesome yeah that's great
yeah i love how they came out they're
really cool
and i guess i should just
clarify
this is a pre-order so
right one that's why there's a cut off
once the cutoff happens they're gonna
make them all and ship them so it'll
take a couple weeks some people were
posting that they already got theirs
online that was because they did a very
small initial run we made like 300
there's like 300 packs or something
i was just so i was just like that's
just a fun thing yeah i don't want to
have i don't want to get like a bunch of
these and just have like tons of packs
yeah
i wasn't sure what the demand would be
but so the first 300 people or whatever
that ordered they got their shipped
immediately so that's why you're seeing
some people with them but if you if you
pre-order expect like a month wait or so
is the is the card guy stuck cam see how
oh he must be stoked oh so i'll be
talking to him he's actually very young
he goes to school he's one person
so this is not like a big corporation
wait what do you mean school like
university or like high school
he's in college yeah
he's an entrepreneur
really good guy really nice yeah he sent
me a very nice message saying it was
basically
i've been chatting with him doing the
social media stuff and he's so nice so
he's stoked yeah everyone involved is
like
very very deserving he's very easy to
work with he's always readily available
too like whenever i dm him he
immediately messaged me back like that's
how he got the sales amount
this guy this is an entrepreneur right
here that's inspiring yeah grind go to
go on shark tank
get make a shark tank pack or don't go
you don't need them no you just go for
the exposure and then your business is
worth like 50 million bucks or something
the instagram post we we planned during
the show he said i got to go to class
so wait one hour and then i can post it
we love a good student too yeah he's
hiring his friends out to help ship the
stuff too and i also got to say i don't
know if he wants me to say this or not
but
in celebration of the massive sale he uh
bought himself a rolex so you know shout
outs to him the what wait the wreck
that guy did yeah he bought him he got
one before zach wait are you [ __ ]
serious he bought himself a rolly he
told you that yeah he sent me
i'm gonna wait i want to see the photo
what the hell
okay player he knows how to he knows how
to spend it
oh my god
dude what the hell dude okay
so funny treat yourself
what do you think zach it's beautiful
beautiful watch are you just saying that
no it's a joke it's just two i mean it's
not though it's not the one i want how
much is it okay this isn't the baller
one i don't know i'm not saying it's not
baller that is a baller [ __ ] dope ass
watch yeah i'm just saying i want a
different type yours is yours is more
expensive
which one do you want submariner
it's a green one right yeah
i think i want to go for the black one
the black one's really cool how much how
much is this one versus how much is the
one you're getting
uh
ballpark i i could be way off but his
could be 12 and mine's like
15. okay so same same question
damn okay well congrats to rap
trading that's crazy bro
everyone's getting [ __ ] paid from
these guys
i'll be buying a i think
an apartment with my money
hey
buying
yeah in sweden it's very common to buy
an apartment instead of renting really
so yeah like a down payment
yeah you take a loan and you pay pay a
loan instead of rent so like a condo
usually even cheaper wait like working
class people are like your friends let's
say who are just working like a retail
job or something just to give an example
they can afford to buy an apartment
yeah you're gonna pay maybe seven to
well i mean you can live outside the
city you can get an apartment for
probably 500 bucks a month with dubai
yeah wow
well the the bank is technically going
to own it because yeah the mortgage well
it's a mortgage but like yeah but then
you just sell it and usually you can
make some profit too soon that's
what a nightmare we live in this country
is i mean in israel too it's impos it's
like impossible too but i think sweden
has like strong uh housing
regulations and stuff
yes i know it's mixed well because when
we were in stockholm
which is the capital
it's like the major metropolis city of
sweden right
yes
so we were in the main part of stockholm
and they were telling us like penthouse
apartments in that area was 500 bucks
damn what the [ __ ] no that's probably
not one thing that were the ones because
stockholm is known to be
extreme like
like 10 folds expensive more expensive
it was cheap like five i remember being
shocked like shocked at the price you
can't get an appointment in my city
i guess we came there from new york
where we were paying 3 500 for like a
studio crazy that was their always
getting like that [ __ ] not that far
something like that yeah
the place we were in new york yeah yeah
wow
yeah it was just like one room wasn't it
and then not i mean yeah well there was
it was there was no kitchen
i mean there was a bedroom
the living area which was and the
entrance was and the bat it was tiny bro
it was the whole thing was so tiny 200
square feet probably
200.
nice neighborhood though great location
yeah for west side
how much percentage do you usually
people usually pay of their
uh monthly 25 is the is the
quote unquote
ideal
i think a lot of people spend more than
that though here oh yeah majority now in
the last couple years everything's
skyrocketed so
i can say it's similar in sweden too so
that makes sense a little bit more
usually even
crazy
right here sometimes a quarter or third
third seems too high to me
a quarter third is is probably usual if
you want to live in the
main city in my city at least
well good i mean that's great news good
for you bud
get out there and
get a slice of heaven
[Applause]
all right guys happy friday get out
there
tgif
rumor has it that gabe is still there
enjoying
his food
second appetizer second entree because
it's friday baby
dj i f
yo i feel like tgif the restaurant could
benefit a lot from a partnership with us
for sure right sponsoring the show oh
just because yes i'm a [ __ ] center
fridays
right if you work at the corporate
office with tgif and you're looking for
please please please
please please tgif
[Music]
we need sponsors desperately
[Music]
want to go out to eat tonight with the
kids
how about without the kids
we have someone
um yeah all right let's talk about it
off there
[Music]
all right
thanks for watching
[Music]
you